Oh, I'm so sad I was muted.
I had a whole monologue and everything.
Hello, hello everybody.
Dad's here right now because he knows I'm eating food.
And he's like, give me your food.
And I'm like, no, it has garlic in it.
Do you want to die?
He's like, damn right, that's how I want to go.
You want to eat to death.
oh my god i'm eating um garlic spaghetti garlic alioli lola
lola spaghetti we have a side order of some meat pies and
then it took it took like an hour plus for the food to get
here almost an hour and a half because the guy who took my
uber eats order had five other deliveries before me and i
was just like oh because I had planned I ordered early too
because I was like I want to eat before my stream not like
yesterday um but the guy had like five orders before me when
he took my order and also the restaurant for my food was
like pretty far away from me so not the greatest also I've
been binge watching I don't know if you guys this is my
algorithm right now um it's black Jack and the laughing
salesman summary shorts watching them it's so good it's like
I like I've heard about black Jack and the laughing salesman
before but obviously you know I never watched the shows
because they're like really old shows they're very old
series so for those who don't know blackjack is created by
the author who did Astro Boy, Gimba, you know, the
grandfather manga.
And it's basically based off of a medical doctor, a surgeon
who doesn't have a medical license performing surgeries and
stuff for random people.
Because for those who didn't know, I did not know this, by
the way.
Or Tezuka, yeah.
The thing about the I didn't even realize this.
But if you guys didn't know, the creator of Astro Boy slash
Kimba slash Blackjack, et cetera, he used to be a doctor
before becoming a manga artist, like before he chased his
passions and everything.
So that's why he had a lot of medical knowledge to create a
series known as Blackjack, which is basically, like I said,
he's like a surgeon who doesn't have a medical license, who
just does like who charges people like a million plus yen
per surgery.
and like some of the shit is like real and then some of this
is just like bullshit like I like like the medical it's like
house you know okay it's like house where some of the
diseases seem real but then the others is just make believe
like it's like there was one I was watching where um oh my
god I'm trying to remember I'm just I've been consuming a
lot of yeah blackjack shorts lately like every day um
because there's so many episodes of it uh yeah there's a
magic stuff going in oh there there was one where um it's
based off a serial killer but we don't know he's a serial
killer yet and um and this guy has a curse where his face
will have tumors growing on his face um and every time the
blackjack tries to like remove the tumors it'll grow back
and it's like a jackal and hide situation where when he has
um he switches personalities when the tumor face takes
possession of him but in the end and then when he removed it
it grows right back basically you find out that uh this guy
that he saved was a serial killer and the tumors was his
good side like taking possession of him and so because he
was tired of he was tired of his bad side killing people so
he possessed he took possession with him by growing tumors
on his face and to curse him and everything.
So it's like, it's like bullshit like that.
Yeah, you're like, what?
Yeah, I know.
So he's like, so like he was trying to stop, he was trying
to stop his evil self from killing more people by, you know,
making him ugly, I guess, by giving him tumors on his face
and making him ugly so he can't lure people in to kill more
people, I guess.
I don't know.
I it was a fucking five.
It was a two minute short guys bear with me It was a two to
three minute short And he had to explain everything in two
to three minutes guys So
Um And then so there's like short like you know there's
stuff like that And there's another one where Um Where was
it oh this one I This one was the fuck This one was a good
one where there was a rich guy who was hiking in some
foreign country and then he fell off a cliff and died.
And there was this other, one of the citizens found him, one
of the local villagers found him and realized he was a rich
guy.
So his plan was to swap faces with the dead guy.
And he called up Blackjack to perform a plastic search.
I know it's crazy, like one surgeon does everything.
a specific uh focus blackjack apparently does plastic
surgery heart transplants uh tumor removal like amputations
everything like he's just he's just a well-rounded i guess
uh and so anyway the the guy the villager calls up blackjack
and was like i'll pay you five million dollars if you
perform this plastic surgery and swap my face with this rich
guy's face so can take over his life and be rich so he does
do that and then the the guy the imposter flies back to
japan and then realize he was like i thought while he was
gone on like while the rich guy was on vacation he lost
everything basically uh like his entire company went under
all he has left is his mom and then his mom was like i'm
sorry we lost everything um but we'll we at least we still
And then, you know, the rich, the, you know, the villager
was like, the imposter was like, what the fuck?
I didn't pay for all of this surgery just to be broke.
Like, I wanted to live the rich life.
And then so now he's like regretting everything and he
hates, he grew, this imposter grew up with a really bad
family life.
He hate like his mom was really abusive and everything.
So he doesn't trust the rich guy's wife.
But then the rich guy's wife is always like trying to take
care of him, making him food and everything, trying to sell
knitted sweaters down the, like, like in like like alleyways
and stuff and then like the imposter saw his mom like his
like you know his fake mom um getting beat up by gangs and
stuff because he's like this is my turf like where are you
doing selling your sweaters here are you gonna pay are you
gonna pay the fee the gang fee so you won't the protection
fee and everything and then he was like oh I'm so sorry with
everything going and he was like realized wait my fake mom
is trying so hard to take care of me even though we're broke
now and then the fake the fake mom uh collapses because
obviously like you know she got beat up and like she was
work she worked herself too hard and everything city the
hospital and then the imposter calls blackjack and was like
please save her like i even though she's not my real mom i
see her as my mom and please can you please fix her can you
please save her perform a surgery because she was like dying
and stuff she has like i don't remember what disease she has
like could be leukemia or some shit but i was like she's not
gonna be saved like obviously she's she's she's it's done
for her like it's over for her anyway so blackjack came over
and and and then the fake mom wakes up and was like and told
to the imposter and was like I'm not your real mom.
And you're like, what?
You're like, what?
What do you mean?
And then you found out that the fake mom was a fake, fake
mom.
And the twist was that the fake, fake mom was actually the
fake mom's maid.
And then the mom actually died.
the rich guy was on vacation in the foreign country so and
then the maid had the same idea as the villager and she was
like she also called blackjack and was like please perform
this plastic surgery on me and and the mom so I can live the
life of well of the wealthy life and everything and so so so
blackjack was like cool yes that's cool thanks for the money
so and so black essentially did two of the same plastic
surgeries and he knew what the fuck was going on this entire
time and so so anyway he swapped the maid and the fake the
dead fake boss face as well and then but then the moment the
surgery was over they lost everything like you know the
company went down and went under and everything so you know
she lost everything as well even with the new face and
everything and and then but then she was like to the
imposter's like even though you're not my real son i still
see you as my son and thank you for giving me the family
i've never had and then the impon and then she dies the
imposter was like no i couldn't because he was about to
confess to his fake mom that he wasn't her real son but then
she confessed first and then she dies and he couldn't
confess to her he couldn't tell her every the the that he
was he also wasn't the real son so the whole moral of the
story was like oh even though they're not your real family
um there is found family and you still build like a family
bond with someone you're not related to like
yeah so so that's basically like that's blackjack and it's
good I've just been binge watching short I know it's like I
feel like it's a little fucked up that current day content
is that everybody instead of watching the show people are
just binge watching the summary shorts but it's so concise
and direct there's no filler you know i'm getting all the
information right off the like it's like oh my it's and it's
so like it draws you in i can't stop i'm sorry i
legitimately can't stop watching them because it like it
draws you in and then i just keep and i just want to watch
more but i just want to watch more of the shorts it's like
it's like there's no it's there's no filler i just i'm
getting everything like bomb pop pop pop pop next like this
is why my attention is so fucked now it's so addictive it
actually is it's so fucking addictive and that is why our
attention span is so fucked anyway another one that i've
been watching is um the laughing salesman this is also by
it's by the creator of dora emong um well i just found out
because of the laughing sales i didn't even realize that did
you guys know the creator of dora emong it's two it's not
even it's actually two authors but the but it's mostly done
by one particular main author but i didn't even know that i
didn't even realize that the manga cup was actually two guys
and they just both have the same art style and everything
they just they just happened to like base like created an
art style together so um the laughing salesman is made by
the other the darker of the two so basically before they
made dora aemon um the one who likes to draw like do like
basically uh one was more about darker storylines more
mature and stuff because the child that you know like the
art style is super childish and everything you would have to
admit the art style is like very kid friendly and stuff so
but the second one um the second op the other art author
like the eviler of the two but the other artist is one more
like childlike stories more one write and draw stories
geared towards children.
And that's why he created Doraemon.
So, but before that, they would work together on various
other collaborations.
And yeah, he's the evil twin, if you want to say.
So the eviler twin, the evil twin, didn't work on Doraemon
at all.
It was the other guy.
But then people like to say, oh, it's by, created by the
same people who created Doraemon.
But Doraemon was mostly done by one guy because it was done
by the guy who is like more towards kid-friendly stuff.
But before then, they would work together and like would
combine both their styles together.
Anyway, so the other guy, he likes to do stories that are
more darker or more mature.
Like, and that was basically the Laughing Salesman.
And the Laughing Salesman is basically a story based of a
demon who's a salesman, and he's always smiling.
And he always, he gives like these, it's like a monkey paw
situation.
So he bumps into people who are suffering in some way, or
there's like a, basically they're going through something,
and they need a solution.
They need like, you know, they need a solution.
And the laughing salesman comes up.
It's like a crossroads demon, basically.
But he's just out, and he's like, oh, I'll make your dreams
come true.
here are my conditions you have to make sure you don't do
this and that because if you do this or that like this whole
thing disappears or like something bad's gonna happen and
almost every time the people um the person he makes the deal
with always fucks up the deal so that's like the whole
premise of the laughing salesman so like every time like
some maybe one or two people will get
not do the thing they told him not to do but majority of the
time like they always fuck up the wish somehow they always
like get too greedy get too curious or anything and then he
comes back and punishes them so one the short i last watched
was basically um i'm trying to remember i watched a lot of
them so um i give one example would be um i'm trying to
think of a good one that i can okay so there's this the mom
um the mom once always wanted to be an idol but she already
is like past that age so she lives vicariously through her
daughter who she she's like basically a dad's mom so um so
she's always pushing her daughter to like um be an idol and
everything and but like the daughter at like at one point
the daughter was like i don't want to be an idol i hate this
i don't i want to go back to being a normal girl and the mom
couldn't take that she was like no you're gonna be an idol
because that's what i want and then the laughing and then
she was like was and then the laughing salesman shows up and
was like i can solve your problem as long as you're as you
can have your daughter wear this necklace and then you hold
on to this control i don't know I remember and then you also
wear the other necklace and every time you want your
daughter to do something She will do it for you So and she
was like and then but if you over but the condition is that
If you overuse the necklace something will go wrong So
obviously she overuses the necklace She overuses it because
she wants her to do everything that like in her vision So
it's like a mind control thing yeah So she wants to do like
you know she wants everything to go perfectly and over again
to the point where um where her daughter just couldn't stop
dancing so she like danced out of the stage and and into the
road and everything and she can't stop it because she
overused the mind control thing and then she was begging the
laughing salesman and he's like please i'll do anything i'll
take her please please stop this whole this fix all of this
i don't want to lose my daughter so laughing salesman was
like all right then you take her place and then he does like
this little finger zap he's like boom and then he zaps her
and then and then it fast forward to her her as a milf
auditioning as an idol everywhere and then like her
daughters be like oh i'm so embarrassed like so so it did a
reversal where like the mom just starts auditioning to be an
idol but she's like obviously like 40 to 50 years old and
like trying to be an idol and everything going to like stage
shows auditioning and everything and your daughter's like
being so embarrassed like oh so um so that's basically
that's basically laughing salesman that's like one of the
episodes i remember another episode i'm trying to remember
the other story i watched so i consumed so many that it's
all blurred together now for me which is that because i'm
saying like like it's a little bad that like this is how we
consume media now but it's like it's so addicting it's it's
so addicting to consume to like wash these shorts because
i'm like what's gonna happen next oh my god i'm so curious
what is gonna happen next guys i found the problem it
started with the laughing cells and now it went to now now
it's blackjack shorts Because it's so, I don't know, each
episode is so interesting.
That can't help it.
I'm trying to remember what the other short that I watched
from The Laughing Salesman is.
And I watched compilations of it, too.
Let's see.
I'll link you guys to a video of it.
But it's like...
Let's see.
is there uh try to find i don't remember a good episode
looking through it oh yeah this one is more mature so like
they there's a lot of there's some sex scenes and some but
not like actually don't show it but it's like super implied
it's like it's like super implied by the way that there's
like people have sex in the laughing cells with oh my gosh
she's barking so much um also loud they give us a super chat
thank you thank you thank you don't you're up but yesterday
was my birthday can't get happy birthday of course you can
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear Hello, happy
birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Oh, my God.
He's singing along with you too.
He's wishing you a happy birthday too.
I'm going to give him a little snack.
All right.
Wait, there's one.
There's one where...
There's one...
This one I remember a lot.
This one where...
And Laughing Salesman.
one of the workers got relocate got hired or relocated into
a division um this um this office man uh got relocated
division where it's like basically the dispensal like what
is it called there's a word for it where basically you're
not fired but they put you in a corner where you don't do
any work or anything but you still make you still earn your
paycheck but basically you're not allowed to do anything um
because they don't want to fire you because then like uh but
they're just still keeping you hostage.
So the guy was moved into that division, and he hated it.
He hated it because he wants to work and everything.
And so the Lafayette salesman came over, and he was like, I
can fix your problem.
I can send someone over there and make it more productive.
And also...
make it so you know you actually have a purpose in your life
so the laughing salesman sends this really beautiful lady
over to his division as a new hire and basically she helps
make he like she basically like cheers everybody up makes
everybody more productive cleans everything and everyone but
there was this other there's what this one guy there's this
one guy in the corner that all he does wants to do was just
cut up newspapers that's all he wants to do he just wants to
cut newspapers and the lady came up to him and it's like let
Oh, I brought you all these newspapers and everything.
Um, here, I'm trying to be so helpful.
And the guy who was cutting news was like, Oh, get away from
me.
I don't need you.
I get away.
Stop getting close to me.
This is my newspapers.
And obviously the main guy got really mad and was like,
don't help him.
He doesn't need you.
He don't help him.
He's, he's an outcast and everything.
So, and then he broke the condition because the laughing
salesman was like, like get away woman this is a man's job
cutting up newspapers and then but then he broke the
condition because the laughing salesman was like um you
cannot interrupt this person that i'm bringing to your
workplace no matter what like let her do her thing you can't
and you can't exclude anybody from her help but he broke
that condition and then later on it was um later on coming
up and and the newspaper guy got the promotion but for some
because he was there he has been in the company the longest
but for some reason he didn't show up so we were wondering
what happened to the newspaper guy and it was later
discovered a couple of days later he apparently took his own
life uh because nobody was there for him basically like no
one was there for him when he needed like it's like heavily
like they literally said say it and everything like oh he
literally like he literally killed himself so um so then the
laughing salesman came up and and he was like oh and
everyone and then later he went to the woman I was like I'm
so sorry that this happened oh like I'm sorry I know because
the woman was like crying like oh if only I helped him you
needed my help if only I helped him and everything like also
imagine all of this style it's so fucking it like it like
it's so fucking weird and and like it's weird but also like
addicting like it's just because you don't expect this in
the dorayemon style art style and everything how dark the
story can be you know like i just don't like it's just such
a weird mixture of things but like i can't stop watching it
so anyway um anyway so Basically, and then the lady, and
then they went, like, you know, he followed the lady into a
hallway, and then she revealed himself to be the laughing
salesman, and she was like, he was like, you should have let
me help her, help him, that was the condition, you wanted a
productive workplace, everyone had to be included, but you
purposely didn't let me help him, so now I shall punish you,
and then he's like, zap, and then in the end, like the
workplace is even a worse living like a worse workplace
basically like it turned it got worse as well like everybody
is depressed now everyone like it's like gross to work in
and then the main guy turned into the new newspaper man so
that's that's the laughing salesman i highly i know i even
though i only consume the shorts i highly recommend the i
highly recommend checking salesman blackjack it's really
good it is i know i mean maybe one day i'll watch the actual
show itself but like me consuming the shorts right now with
my limited time has been going pretty well
i've it's been working for me but i highly recommend
checking it out because i've been enjoying this the series
through shorts damn yeah it has some really up storytelling
um um anyway let's go play mine 007 i've been um i've been
really addicted to this game i've been thinking about it
that's why i'm so sorry i'm recording fans i really want to
play more because it actually has been really really fun oh
yeah speaking of like because i was thinking about blackjack
i don't know you guys heard about it it showed up my
algorithm or my twitter algorithm but there's a there's a
well um I don't know if he's like super famous, but he's
like an up and coming Japanese VTuber indie.
And apparently he did an endurance stream for 100.
He would end the stream when he gets 100 million yen.
I don't know if anybody saw this.
I was like, how much is 100 million yen?
And I looked it up.
It was 630,000 US dollars.
So you would think, how long did it take for this Japanese
indie VTuber to get $630,000 US dollars?
An hour and 30 minutes.
An hour and 30 minutes?
He reached 100 million yen.
I don't!
Oh, it's like, oh, because I didn't know how much a hundred
million yen was.
Because, like, you know, I don't have a fucking conversion
in my head.
Yeah, yeah, but um, what was he doing?
He was just talking to his chat.
Wait, let me say I bookmarked it.
I was, because, like, I didn't know, I didn't know how much
it was until, like, I looked at the, I was like, oh, good
for him.
And I looked at the stream.
And then I was like, oh, an hour and 30 minutes.
And then I did the conversion rate.
And then I was just like, and then you can even see, like,
like, his stream was crashing because of how many Akas he
was receiving.
Like, it was just every millisecond there was a new Akasupa.
It was fucking wild.
It was, let me see if I can grab the clip.
I don't know.
I know he's like an, I read that he was like an, and comrade
like he's been grinding for a while but he's getting more
and more popular uh lately
oh my god that um my god in an hour and 30 minutes too
you're doing something wrong
um chicory thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you on
my local time so today's my birthday Though I can't watch a
stream properly due to my workplace, but I still cheer you
as my Oshi.
I'm ready for an upcoming birthday.
Oh, thank you, Chikori.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Chikori.
Yay!
I hope you have a great birthday.
I'm happy to still be your Oshi.
And for all the support you've given me.
I can find I think I bookmarked it let me see did I bookmark
it oh my god did not bookmark it I mean it's easy to look it
up I just I can just google it or uh hundred million yen let
me just look that up but actually I have in my history
because I was doing conversion rates I was like what is a
hundred I was like doing conversion I should have the
history of it of me googling a hundred million yen and then
finding it on twitter okay there we go i found it was next
to the there you go it was fucking wild and people were like
clearly i was in the wrong profession i think i'm in the
wrong profession i need to do like what the fuck what the
fuck is he doing oh my god yeah here what was this oh it
wasn't 100 yeah like it's crazy you can see the moment It
just doesn't stop.
Like, I was just like, oh my god.
Like, it's literally a wall.
A wall of Akka's and it doesn't stop.
It doesn't.
I know.
I was like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I was rage baited, guys.
Guys.
I got I got clickbaited I got clickbaited guys I just
realized apparently after a couple of hours of it going
viral guys I got clickbaited he turned all his comments into
he turned all his comments into super chats he and everyone
got clickbaited I just read the YouTube comments
The thing is his chat, look, look, no, guys, they didn't say
anything until the thing is they kept the joke up until I
fell asleep, I guess.
I was gonna say this, you're not allowed on the, sorry, I
was spreading misinformation.
I, no, we all, no, you don't understand, look at the
Twitter, look at the tweet, nobody was saying the truth
until now look at look at the comments in the tweets guys
wait how do i do that wait i want to do that's fucking funny
as hell i don't give me a sec i want to know how i can do
that that's twitter spread misinformation look at the tweet
that's pretty that's pretty funny i'm gonna that's really
that's pretty good.
I was just like, oh my god, how did this guy get a hundred
million?
This information age is here.
I, look, look, I will say this.
They, they, this stream was two days ago.
Guys, I will say this, this stream was two days ago.
And then people confessed this last night.
This was confessed last night.
But this man kept this.
Everybody kept telling me this was a hundred million for two
days.
And then they confessed it wasn't real last night.
This is making it I was bamboozled.
We all for it they kept up the illusion for two days
straight I was a victim I think I was a victim in all of
this I didn't know where he got this I mean like look at the
comments on the tweet look at the comments everybody thought
it was real so I thought it was real and I looked at the
YouTube video and I read the comments and nobody confessed
until last night.
Of course, the day I decided to tell the story was when they
decided to confess up.
Of course.
Wait, I want to do that.
I'm going to steal.
I'm going to yank my yank.
You wouldn't be needing that.
I want to, I don't know where he got that code from.
It must be from Boof.
It's always on Boof.
I'm going to try and find it.
I'm going to be played but i'm gonna find this right now i
need a no now yoink you won't be needing that i'm guys i'm
sorry but i want to see how he does it how did he do it oh i
got next year's april fool's idea why wait next year when i
can do it right now there must how did he do it he must have
got it okay it could be on twitter though don't keep chat
I'm the endurance stream a hundred million five hundred
thousand dollars that's gonna be my endurance stream let's
see how where did he find it I need a no all right wait let
me see I'm sorry I know I should be playing the game but
Like, nah, I'm curious.
Confess!
One million dollars.
Yeah, stream doesn't stop until I get one million dollars.
These lies don't say it's for charity.
It's not.
It's going in my pocket.
And then, oh my god, the biggest rage bait.
People will be so fucking mad.
I take the idea.
It's like...
It's like, it's like people who like adapt Japanese films
and anime to like America.
I'm doing that.
I'll do that.
I'm doing that right now.
I'm like, I'm taking his idea and bringing it to NA.
And that caused like a lot of controversy, just like the
Feet Juice.
I got, you're right.
I do it before someone else takes the idea.
Don't, don't.
I'll be the, I'll be the Netflix death note, the Netflix
adaptations.
Netflix is signing the rights as we speak.
I'm going to tap this in America.
Oh my gosh, he doesn't even say where he got it from.
He's so smart.
He's, I need the counter, too.
Like, he has, like, a counter that adds to, like, how does
he do it?
He has a counter that adds the money, too.
I need to write this down.
I need
Yeah, and then Oh, if you guys look at his Twitter account
Look at his Twitter account He's like, he's like, oh no This
is probably a bad idea Right now Because like, um Because
like people were like People were making news articles About
the whole thing and everything And then he's like Shit,
should I have spread misinformation?
He's just like, wait, oh shit.
It's breaking out of my circle.
He did not expect it.
Man, this was a little too successful.
Dexerto, I'm looking at you.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for my dexerto article.
My joke has broken containment.
I'm ready.
When I have my Netflix adaptation, I'm ready, Dexerto, for
that article.
Jake Lucky, get ready for this.
Like, oh, no, it's breaking containment.
Oh, my God.
I wish I, I wish I know.
I wish I know what code.
I know there's a code for this.
It has to be somewhere.
I need to find it.
Maybe he did get a custom code.
You know, I'm a commissioner.
someone.
Fuck this.
I'll commission someone for it.
The Dexterito article.
New new stream idea.
Just dropped, guys.
Hot off the press.
Ready for its Netflix adaptation.
I'm bringing this to America.
And everyone just has to, like, look at the last stream.
Aiders will say it's fake.
oh boy all right okay okay now we play the game I just
wanted to talk about that all right press F to play
all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
one day my OSHA will learn to not trust the first thing she
sees on Twitter it even got people in them it went viral to
the point that I was getting the tweet guys it literally
left Japan now I'm ready to now i'm gonna try and get the
licensing to to take to adapt it in america
all right here we go resume game
yeah so wowed escape jp twitter that's when you know that's
where the wild tweets go up do you see the tweet have you
ever seen like those crazy ass japanese tweets and then um
when with the translate button and then um um and there was
this really wild one where this japanese man was tweeting
about how his wife jerked him off and then he was like oh it
was so good and everything and then i ate breakfast here's a
picture of my breakfast and then one guy one english guy
quote retweeted it and was like please get rid of the
translate button elon musk
He's like, please give me an option to turn off
auto-translate, Elon.
Like, I do not want this on my feed.
It was a really, that's me giving like a summary of the
actual tweet was fucking wild.
It was presented to the Slovakian delegation.
Strategically, we need at least three playbooks reaching the
desired outcome yeah oh what were the topics it was it was
like the the actual tweet itself was a lot more detailed
that's me giving like a spark note version of it he was very
detailed about what his wife was doing and but then the last
part was like anyway here's my breakfast here's a picture of
my breakfast right after uh Wesley thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you speaking birthdays Today is the
birth of Ian Fellum, the creator of James Bond.
He was born in London in 1819 or 1908.
Yeah, it's like, this is why the base, this is why God took
down Babel's Tower.
Praise me.
Sorry.
Well, that's right.
You better be sorry.
You walked into my path.
Sorry.
Didn't see you there.
All right.
always in the on the right side Q lab 9th I might go to Q
lab what's on the 9th floor though I'll go to enough oh this
is the 9th floor all right Q lab I'm
on the right side of history you better have something
efficient for me Q
so one more round of prototyping on the pen quick as you can
ah kio what does he have just finish the game glad you're
enjoying oh my god oh you had early access right you think
you was super chat thank you thank you because isn't this
game supposed to be like longish that's crazy you you must
have like grinding this entire game last three days i missed
you at the service yes i kept to the back never did like
funerals all that black yeah doesn't match his colors i'm so
sorry you must with you be okay you were a fine lot i know
you'll make them proud 15 hours that's still pretty long
especially if you're exploring everything let's get you feel
ready because like what i like about this game is that
there's no force collectibles that you have like a
collectathon thing to pad time there's not a lot of filler
it's all like everything seems to like durability tests on
Everything seems to like contribute to the main story.
Which is why I like.
Quite clever what you did back on the plane.
How did you know the watch had a tracker?
That's the 21st century cue.
My toaster has a tracker.
And the phones are always listening.
I assume you've worked out how to switch it off as well.
Time will tell.
I thought as much.
Oh, and Bond.
One more thing.
new earpiece bone conductive microphone you attach it
directly to the skin ultra thin virtually undetectable okay
for my new air pod before you go there are some new items of
field equipment you might be interested in new stuff i will
be interested in that sir i like new shiny things there are
a couple of new pieces that are going through final testing
ahead of field certification Reader listens.
This is why you shouldn't get smart fridges I heard some
smart fridges like listen to what like listen to you and
like It helps it like suggest you stuff to buy too Of
course, Q the laser strap and flash mine have just passed
final certification excellent Come on And I won't wear you
know and I won't wear my tinfoil hat The laser strap has a
laser strap But we can install Doom on it, though.
Equivalent exchange.
Let the government listen to...
Let the corporate company sell my data.
But at least I can play Doom.
It's the little things.
It can also disarm hostiles.
Oh, that's cool.
That's all gone.
Perfect for when you don't want to attract unwanted
attention.
I'll take anything that gets me closer to 009.
We aim to please.
But that's not all.
Over here, we have the flash mine.
You can't install Doomwater or Samsung breaks your fridge,
though.
But you know what you can do?
Not buy a Samsung fridge.
There's an easier alternative loop around that.
Buy a smart fridge not made by Samsung.
It's not like they have a monopoly on it.
It won't work if all you do is The flash mine uses molecular
bonding To adhere to any surface and operates on a proximity
trigger Just the thing if you need to cover your escape Or
leave someone a nasty surprise Give it a try Alright
Oh Is this lethal?
Very good Now throw it at the statue Can I throw it at the
intern?
Try it
you are a remarkably fast kinesthetic learner no time to
waste q hmm that does that doesn't look that lethal like i
wouldn't you think that's fatal guys you think he's all
right here we have the dart phone smoke pods flash mine and
laser strap yeah your maximum loadout is two in addition to
your new watch according to thea you should expect hostile
terrain with a relative humidity below 25% and to encounter
organized and motivated.
You might zoom these out.
Motivated.
I'll show them motivated.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, let's grab.
Okay, we want to try, I want to try new stuff.
Try the laser strap and then the flash buy.
I think that'll do.
Thanks, Bridget.
You're welcome, Bond.
Bring everything back in one piece.
going if you 009 knows greenway he knows mi6 but he doesn't
know you bond that's your advantage really i feel like i was
chasing him down though i was oh my i just realized guys
okay i was re-watching a little bit my last bot and there
was a moment where um we bumped into the maze and she was
like oh yeah like i saw a put like um i saw the the sky and
he looks just like the bell uh the chef and he looks just
like the bellhop and i was like what are their twins huh and
then it was twins like i made it like an off comment joke i
was like it could just be twins like and then they were
twins i oh my i'm so i'm so good at this game i am the
international spy good to see you sorry about what happened
Yeah, she knows.
Damn, I always see it coming.
Under there's any new gadgets.
Oh, that's a new gadget.
Yeah, I was going to say, didn't they literally saw me
face-to-face?
What's this new gadget?
I don't need an infrared scanner to tell me that.
If you get the dependencies and image lagged down, it will
be a sweet addition to the AR feature set.
That's the kind of thing Dr. Tan in Taksims would really go
for.
oh shit that press a button oh i'm tired now oh it's because
my it's because the face is linked to the okay to like the
number keys so i actually pressed the number key okay oh
which one was that
fix it now there we go oh that's me extra tight there we go
it's because when i press alt let me turn that off i forgot
they're all like linked to the alt key just like abracadabra
i don't even notice that all right let me turn that off real
quick What the fuck is it?
Anyway, uh...
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, alright.
That was, like, literally the only thing that I accidentally
had turned on.
And I happened to click on it.
Look at the readings.
The scanner says he's hotter than you, Monty.
Whoa.
And he's right, too.
Wait, I want to see.
Whoa!
That's...
That might be dangerous.
Guys, I think I might actually need to see a doctor.
I'm fully red.
That's not...
Is that a health concern?
Should I be experiencing these temperatures right now?
99.96% of all light that falls on it.
So, uh, it's black.
99.96% of all light.
Got it.
It's really black.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, it is.
It's like the blackest black car out there.
I'm super at.
Is there anything else?
Are there new gadgets?
What's this?
I love how every time you go to this lab, there's new
technology.
Three, two
Whoa, I'm walking away from that you think that's fatal I
don't think walking away is the is the least I didn't lock
you was the least of your concerns I think we got five.
We got identify the bodies later I know it's ridiculous, but
I always imagine when we're all riding the 250 X It's a
dangerous game, how you mustn't get attached i know that
that's all right i'll ride it in his place you think they'll
shook a program back down over m's dead yeah bodies you mean
pieces though bright in his lot best we can do is continue
what we're doing it's out of our hands suppose so hedgehogs
are next i'm up for that
uh i'm that one thank you super chat thank you thank you i
vote to keep the tire eyes and bond mood after losing
expendable not childhood best friend aid no he'll never go
get close to another man ever again double seven monroe give
me five minutes i'm almost done running the benchmarks is
that the you know how's it looking off the charts and he's
even finished with it whoever gets to drive this will think
he's died and gone to heaven one That's going to be me.
Let's just say his eyebrows won't be making an appearance
until sometime around Q3.
Jesus, classic Barry.
To be fair, he did prove the thing works.
Yeah, on his face.
Where is he now?
Hospital.
He took it quite well.
He was laughing and joking with the ambulance crew.
However, the optimist.
Indeed.
Why to pause?
I was taking a swig.
Of course.
Of my drink.
Friday drinks are scripture.
Also, you know what's crazy?
I need a wig man if you're game.
Whoa.
good stuff speaking of swigs you know how I talked about
feet juice earlier I just found out we're technically one
degree away from the feet juice lady from the feet juice
cosplayer because the cosplayer that was wearing the senpai
squad stuff photo shoot was the feet juice cosplayer
we're one degree away from her she's the same She's the same
person who was in the photo shoot.
Yeah, I just found out because I looked at her Twitter Um,
because she revealed herself on Twitter.
I'm like, that's me.
I'm the feet juice cosplayer Um, by the way, I did more
research about it and apparently it was originally so over
five because I was curious about the whole thing and also it
went mainstream like news like actual Like actual news
normie news
because you know it's a it's a it's an interesting story and
they were originally charging it for five dollars and then
the because of them by the way this is all was one day it
was all one day one night too the fact that they made more
than a thousand dollars within a couple of hours at night
because it was an aftercon party and apparently apparently
originally it was sold for five dollars and then because of
demand they've up the price to 30 dollars per drink but yeah
um she like she like came out on twitter being like to be
like yeah that was me and then like you know everyone now
knows who the cosplayer was it was that did the whole thing
and and then I looked at her Twitter and I saw the senpai
squad photo shoot and I was like oh my god I'm one degree
away from feet shoes lady she was literally part of the toky
bird senpai squad photo shoot of all the ads that we took
pictures of like she was the model
Small world.
I'm part of history!
Hello?
What's this you're testing out?
Yeah, small world, indeed.
What is she testing?
Just a teddy bear.
She's just Brenda.
Are you trying to kill someone?
Nice one, Derek.
really sensitive how was i to know but what what does the
bear do i want to know what the bear does
soon you're gonna be on the news yeah with my this with the
endurance stream to a million dollars that's i'm gonna i'm
gonna do it It does bear things.
There are things around here.
Oh, look at all the little Easter eggs.
Okay, that's where I came from.
Is that everything?
Oh, that's mad.
He's like, I better get that cut.
He better leave some of that money for me, too.
Oh, my God.
Why did he get closer?
Hey!
Why?
No!
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's test that gun out.
Waters, you have a package for me.
Right, you are.
One MI6 standard issue service pistol.
No need to sign.
Yes.
Alright, I finished my food.
I'm gonna put this away
Oh my god I need to like Also remind That reminds me I need
to get my water I left my water in the kitchen I'll be back
I'll get water
Hey Now I'm back No more distractions We play the video game
Give me that gun It's safe in my hands You know I was like
watching Some other people play James Vaughn?
Whatever.
Just because I was, like, curious on how other people were
playing it.
I think I was the only one that was just...
I was one of a few people that was actually using mouse and
keyboard instead of controller.
I thought it was funny because everyone was, like, you know,
not using the license to kill feature where it was like,
like, hit, hit, shot, headshot, headshot.
Everyone was actually trying to use gadgets and stuff.
And I was just like, oh, I'm just so efficient, you know?
I'm sorry for being such an efficient killer.
And not use my stuff here.
I was literally in the training room.
I want to be at the top of the kill fee.
Wait, what?
You can't just do this to me.
simulation.
This is why Doki is the top of my, the class, yeah.
It's not fair.
So I started blasting.
Oh, the one in the middle?
All right.
I'm not even on the fucking... Wait, oh, there it is.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm gonna do, say all that, and I'm gonna whiff shots.
do i need to do headshots or no i actually don't even know
exhale hold squeeze what on oh i do okay headshot is more
points all right now i know reload yep all right headshot is
more
thousand all right what is it all right number three i can
do better i didn't realize headshot counts i thought it was
just a target practice
all right oh i flicked i'm sad i flicked it well i could
literally just aim it
oh my god reload read it and weep there we go That's what I
like to see that's right get out of here paper doesn't cut
it for me.
I'm afraid It's a piece peopleers give me a real challenge
Easy I think I could have got I think I could have got 2k
But then with the last shot oh wait How's the antique turns
out they don't make the kind of sleeping gas that was used
back in the day We're about to test an alternative.
Care to be a guinea pig?
Sorry.
I have someone to be.
Wait, I want to do it.
Bond, come on.
Don't be a pussy.
Also, who's calling me?
Mushy-mushy.
Let's start our next mission.
We've dilly-daddled enough.
Ignore Gerald.
He's an idiot.
The rest of us heard about what happened and that you're
going back out there.
Some of us would love to be going with you.
I've applied for field training myself.
Anyway.
Yeah, but you're a nerd.
I just wanted you to know the way behind you.
All the way.
Thanks.
I think you're going to stay in the lab.
Field work is not for nerds.
Absolutely not.
We need to act now.
Wait, I want to talk to Basil from accounting.
Does Basil still hate me?
Hey, Basil.
counting.
Hello, Basil.
Ah, Mr. Bond.
Good to have you back in one piece.
Don't worry.
Mr. Greenway has already signed off on the damages.
Damages.
One standard issue earpiece destroyed.
One special edition cue watch.
Oh, my eyes like he thinks it's my fault.
I literally got beat up.
Does that sum it up?
Don't forget the hat plus one hat.
All right, the chauffeur outfit must have been like $20.
Mr. Bond, mine is keeping the lights on.
Just warming up, Basil.
My dad, he so mean to me is it is a tough love it's just
tough love why is so mean i wasn't the only one oh what
about the funeral huh monroe's funeral that costs a lot of
money whitlock did feed some of his sources nuggets that we
see slowly gaining traction anything we can do to support
that yes we have several initiatives running already full
breakdown in your daily all right we're talking about walk
away.
All right.
Is there anything interesting here?
Any gossip to dish?
Anything I can eavesdrop?
The tragic chess championship explosion.
Slovakian opposition accuses government of neglecting safety
inspections after budget cuts.
Politicians never disappoint when it comes to public
outrage.
Even when the reason for it is pure fantasy coming from our
office.
This one's good.
Three historical sites destroyed in freak accidents on the
same day timing suggests that the global events could be
connected not even one of ours spurious correlation is a
social media darling they pop up in their own and the ball
starts rolling what's the latest they say m is in the
doghouse girl pr disaster that is slovakia oh if james
hadn't been there not pointing any fingers just laying out
the facts I suspect the one thing that might keep M in her
chair is if you lads produce a culprit.
No way.
A government job has got political seating.
So, who would have thought us getting involved in
international affairs can cause a political outcry?
Oh my god.
No way.
Surely.
I still haven't received the farce.
I requested half an hour ago.
seen who would have thought it's me again we need to eyes on
it before it gets sent off and the other one it's never
happened before i know the actions of my consequences of
being a international spy
me getting involved in another country's business who could
have thought say it ain't so come to you.
A diplomatic crisis will do that.
Today was rough.
How are you holding up?
You needed to show me something.
Oh?
Here's the lady.
Oh, you don't recognize Agent Roth.
I believe you shared an Aston Martin.
Charlotte Annabelle Roth.
Senior operational officer at the DGSC headquarters in
Paris.
You can't be serious.
We chatted.
Nice lady.
Retires next year to spend time with her grandchildren who
was the woman then that's what I'd like to find out Ah, so
it wasn't her Any news on Ronson?
They'll be keeping her in an artificial coma until the
brain's under the disease disease.
Yes, she's I'm sorry Kingsley's dead Yes I'm sorry.
I hated her.
She was so mean that's what they she gets stitches get
stitches I hope she doesn't rest in peace All right,
snitches get fucking stitches Did you manage to ID the marks
I fought at the airfield?
But she was so mean Rat terminated My teammate died, let's
go I
Rest in pain.
Who are the blonde twins?
You match on the blonde twins.
Nico and Taro Murta.
Assassin duo from Tampere, Finland.
Highly adept at unarmed combat, improvisation, and social
infiltration.
These are ruthless operators, James.
Ice cold killers.
I know.
Oh my god.
He's Agent 4 and Agent 7.
Ready for that mission brief.
What you got for me?
Come.
Let's have a look.
I'm not going to lie, you have got your work cut out for
you.
Greenway, perfect timing.
009.
After he escaped Slovakia, we tracked Bond's watch to a
field outside of the Syrian village, Jab al-Uthman, where
the unregistered cargo plane was abandoned.
A wide Thayer sweep picked up his trail 36 hours later in
the Turkish province of Shenlurfa.
From here, he embarked on a complex route, eventually
bringing him to Egypt, where we lost his trail, for good.
However, despite significant effort being put into obscuring
transport payments, Thayer managed to pin two of the charter
private jets to the Pirate King of Barthes.
The Pirate King?
You heard me right.
The One Piece?
What do we have on this Barthma?
Abducted by militants at the age of 10 along with his little
sister.
Trained as a child soldier until age 12 when Barthma turned
on his captors.
Killing five and escaping.
Spent half a decade looking for a sister.
to no avail your sister is dead he entered the world of
piracy for the next two decades he rose like a shooting star
turning random endeavors into a well-organized international
business empire all culminating in moritania when he claimed
a ship graveyard must get the bounty that's the main black
market hub on the african continent major league weapons
bizarre if i'm not mistaken indeed and with the clientele to
match aleph is a cesspool of military and pmc personnel
rubbing shoulders with rebel groups and criminal
organizations alike how does all that connect to 009 that's
the thing it doesn't which is probably why he managed to
stay invisible for more than a decade however with the new
intel things are starting to line up and considering the
amount put up to facilitate double he's working with the
parking to believe that he is part of bavma's inner circle
damn he's so now he has so connected he's so good networking
guys go to a left Find 009 and bring him back.
Everything depends on your success.
No pressure.
This game will now go on for a thousand episode.
Almost there.
I said, wait me when we get to a left.
And I'd like take a shortcut.
Not a morning person, are we?
Just drive.
Oh.
i thought this i thought i could get up this rock i can get
up this rock though we're back in sandland
every no matter where we go it always leads back to sandland
if i pop the radio on why blend in you don't need a radio to
do that right now that's where the uh the eye patches and
the wooden legs are for Wow, this road is a little bumpy,
guys.
I'm taking the scenic route.
Wee-moo.
How do you want to play this once we're inside?
Kabuto 9 is bound to be paranoid.
That makes him dangerous.
He's expecting us to make him move after Slovakia.
Not us.
Somebody else.
Even the game was like, please, drive the road.
Oppensify.
Once we get inside, we need to get to...
I heard his car is driving on the wrong side of the road.
Yeah, they really need to fill in these potholes.
They really pave a better road for us.
I'm stress testing the game, guys.
Not getting past that.
Take a right.
And if Bavma isn't an option...
Oh, there's a car crash.
Oh, yeah, I heard you can't run over people in this...
game because um they're trying to be like your james bond
you don't run over people so they purposely made it so that
drive assist oh my god my my smart car i was like stop this
is a tesla god they're like there is it's taking control of
the wheel
supposed to be playing James Bond.
So like they're trying so hard to make you immerse in the
character because they're like James Bond would not do that.
I mean true.
True.
But what if it's James Bond's intrusive thoughts?
Pass never dies.
But my James, my, in my head cannon, James Bond would run
over this person.
If I hadn't followed my hunch back in Slovakia, more people
would have died.
We both know that.
So stop trying to cut me off at the knees every chance you
get.
I'll think about it.
All right, here we go.
We're entering the town.
If it was a Tesla, you would hit people.
Then it turned the odd drive off right before so you can't
blame it.
the super chat thank you thank you i'm the test of the auto
drive copy that money penny heading inside stop touching
your ear what i said stop touching your bloody ear i got
here oh why do people touch their ear i get to i guess like
when it's like a walkie-talkie Why do spies touch their
ears?
Is it like a controller when you're doing walkie-talkie?
This place never changes.
Ah.
12 o'clock.
I would assume like now the earpieces can like do both ways
now.
That's why he's like stop touching it because he's like, we
don't have these outdated you don't have these outdated
technology anymore it's two-way now no doubt locals dealers
fabulous men join you try not to draw attention to yourself
how they're playing hey there's us there's you guys right
here super chicks is that a street fighter oh my god wait
this place is great they have their own personal arcade you
think you think they have dental here
oh oh it's just sniper yeah they're having a fighting game
tournament right now it's combo breaker at your local you
know they might be pirates but they still have culture combo
breaker at your next pirate at your next pirate layer pills
and mean whoa whatever you need I have all can get yeah
there's they might be pirates but they're still part of the
SGC make it all go away with just one pill come and see Bows
with blue or food in rush with reds come on over we take the
red pill or the blue pill Just browsing
Wow Meat and pills to go with it
Oh cigars 140 dollars?
Oh, it's from kuba kuba Just fire it up and breathe it in
they just came in today just sold my first pack a few drugs
and steak I know right what a perfect combination me
personally I find cigarettes to be for the restless do they
you have vapes or a grand kubana are for those of us who
possess the gift of patience and money of course not today
all right oh my god wait they are doing FGC It is.
Look at that.
You deaf, Taurus.
We said move easy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Well, you found it.
I didn't mean to.
I broke.
Oh, shit.
I need a rope.
Wait.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Get out of here.
They were having their own situation contained.
They were having their own Smash Bros.
tournament.
And I came in to smash.
I'll bear that in mind if the day job doesn't work out.
No, you ruined their tournament.
They were in the finals.
Look, I entered a tournament not won, guys.
And now it's not drawing attention to yourself working out.
He started it.
Mark it's this way What's this?
Clothing a such a clothing accessory for both men and women.
I'm good Come back when you have some taste
Burners Damn
a better deal than anyone here hey over here i know what you
need a pre-loaded crypto wallet man that he does know what i
need all you do is plug this in and it steals while you
smile a collection of guys guys i heard like i guys i heard
there was a new minecraft Come on.
Yeah, can you guys click on the link for me and download it
so we can play together?
Don't take too long to decide, brother.
Not for me, thanks.
Ooh, that looks good.
Yeah, he knows this stuff.
A pre-loaded crypto wallet in my James Bond game?
Please download the EXE and make sure so you can play with
me.
I love the world building this game.
It's crazy.
log it's crazy oh yeah she has tea yeah um can you also like
open your crypto wallet real quick
you look like you have a sort of teas including black tea
sweet tea green tea and even english tea
Thanks, but my body's a temple.
One that doesn't serve mystery T's.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you're British.
What do you mean?
That's blasphemy.
Revoke his British passport.
Tempting, but no.
Alright.
Yeah, what do you mean?
You're British.
Really a people person.
Something rogue PMC outfit.
boys parked outside.
Which boys?
I'm looking.
I'm just visiting the market.
Oh, this place is cool.
It has everything.
Do you think they sell 50-80s?
So this is the left.
A cesspool of the Sahara.
Bet they don't put that in the guidebook.
We're in the lions then, Bond.
Everyone here is a threat.
So watch your back.
I'm window shopping.
up there people on the left
the beating heart of this city all we have asked in exchange
for your protection and the place at our oh there's the
parakeet is but a small token of appreciation i mean tarik
here does not agree with that sentiment why the console my
pc flash for a second after opening your your exe oh it's
just downloading extra mod packs now don't worry about it
thank you thank you you forgot to download the extra texture
pack so the so the mod helps you download it
don't worry about it would you want to play minecraft with
me
he tells me there's a child a girl he fears for her life she
needs medication expensive kind That is where his
contributions went.
Our protection is for the care of everyone.
And our great city.
Not gonna lie.
Be able to build a city from ground up.
It's pretty.
Men, women.
Pretty much.
It's a really good accomplishment.
What kind of monsters would we be if we denied this child
the care she requires?
What kind of man would he be if he did not fight for her
care?
You would be no kind of man.
market as well in his city let it be known that's very
insane the child shall want for nothing from this moment on
oh shit
oh bring it to the girls the girls trouble in paradise well
you know what I'd vote for him.
Watch out for the snakes.
After watching that performance, I think it's clear Ali is
our man.
Shouldn't take too much to twist his arm.
Let's go twist it.
He's just trying to protect this city.
He's got to control it.
Say what you want about him.
He really keeps this place together.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
When he speaks, the people listen.
And they think twice before doing something stupid.
Because they know if they're caught.
Then wind up on the end of that blade of his.
You know, he stepped in when I had that dispute with Bakery.
That could have gotten bloody.
But he heard about it and pulled us aside.
Treated us as equals.
Can't say the same for Ali.
Ali's a rat.
Bhavma's got presence.
When he walks into a room, he commands it.
Exactly.
He's not just...
He seems like a pretty alright lady.
He's got a ringstrip.
Ray around here.
What's so bad about him?
Just, you know.
Just like, he steals one or two boats per year.
That ain't too bad.
It might be a pirate, but, you know, he created a city.
Nothing wrong with that.
You gotta pay the city somehow.
That's the price of freedom, babies.
Yeah, but he was a really bad guy.
He even told us he was a really bad guy
Speak with Bacard Ali If he was a tyrant Why does the city
look so cool to live in?
He was trying to keep the child alive Dari, the tourist at
12 o'clock here for the auction Uh Speak to Bacard Ali Where
is he?
Yeah, if he was such a bad leader, why does he have the FGC
community here?
I'll be right back.
I'm sure you will.
All right, I'm returning Greenway.
Yeah, if Tyron, why?
Cool.
How do you think it went?
Well, you're still in one piece, so better than I expected.
It's an auction.
We're not getting inside or near Picard Ali without an
invite and $100,000.
How'd you want to play this?
Split up.
I'll work the invites you source the cash.
How am I supposed to find 100 grand out here in the desert?
Oh, I don't know.
Luck, charm.
Isn't that how you've gotten things done in the past?
I have to get 100 grand?
This is my trial run for a 1 million.
Oh, I'm going to start beating people up, aren't I?
I need $100,000.
You know I can't do that, James.
Looks like I'm getting my hands dirty then.
Where is the...
Oh, that's cool.
Oh my god, wait, do you think that's good?
You need to become a streamer.
And if it's money you need to make in a laugh, you've come
to the right place.
I'm Normala.
What do you want to know?
Uh, anything I can do for you?
Must be something you want that I can have to play street
fight in real life.
He runs a cup's gown flashy little setup always a big crowd
gathered round He's offering up a red jewel as a prize The
jewel of Jahari.
Let me guess We'd like to get your hands on it lost it in a
bet to him I want it back Get it for me and I'll make it
worth your while You'll find him next to the shoe stall to
the right of the fight pit of the fight pit anything out
here worth chasing had someone come by earlier trying to buy
weapons wanted to pay in crypto told him to get lost it's
wrong with crypto it's useless out in the market oh i guess
everybody has a crypto wallet just go through the tunnel
what do you mean was gonna give you like five bitcoin that's
so much money got anything else for me keep your eyes open
and you're exactly she wouldn't reject crypto like that this
place is full of opportunities especially if you're willing
to take a few risks thanks see you again unless it's some
fucking meme coin.
Alright, where is the fight pit?
Yeah, should have paid an NFTs, you're right.
I only have NFTs.
Would you like to have a board ape?
Knock, knock.
I don't even have here.
The details of criminal deal.
Jolten a backup postcard.
Container yard, unit 12 b 11 p.m come alone 500k and
unmarked bills okay unit 12b come on lazar off shouldn't
have left this lying around oh it's just to collect
collectibles i guess yeah
at least it's not you in that ring getting the snuck kicked
out of you by a couple of looms yeah we need to find the
ring wow this market is crazy there's so many things to do
here oh there's a lucky cat no matter where you go there's
always a lucky cat even in the middle of a desert yeah yeah
best prices in the market brought my own thanks you buy from
me to try your life I guarantee all you have to do is no
sift oh wait I could do this when 30 000 put this is easy no
no spiel here my friend just you that's gone and a big pile
of cash what's the catch he told the targets what's the
catch oh i don't have 30k yet all right i'll have to grab
money real fast and come back
things are tight not just for me for everyone alice raised
taxes again he's crippling us You saw what happened.
What's wrong with taxes?
We're finishing up our business today.
What?
Oh, no.
What happened?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Are you...
Oh, my God.
Oh, who could have done such a thing?
More than you do.
My dad grabbed $3,000.
Okay, I need...
You only had $3,000 on you?
I should grab his crypto wallet.
Hey, what's wrong?
Don't you like living here?
I need more batteries.
Must be more people that I can pick pocket.
No, he doesn't touch.
He doesn't carry money on him.
Oh, it may be here.
Oh.
I know I eavesdropped this You'll figure something out Where
there's a will there's a way, right?
Zora you told me the deal was locked in place You said you
could secure the weapons for the cause with the money on the
crypto wallet now you're telling me it's a no-go We don't
have hard currency you knew that no no Don't try again It'll
make us look weak.
I need to call Andrew He's got context out here.
Maybe we can find a way to convert that crypto to cash in a
hurry.
Just sit tight and wait for my call.
I can help you convert it.
Just click on this link, that link to my new Minecraft mine.
Money penny, I need you to track a phone for me.
I'm looking at the caller right now.
You'll need to hack the phone first.
Then I'll be able to look onto the signal.
I can do that.
Trust my eyes!
Whoops.
Hacking?
Oh, whoops, I lasered him instead of hacking.
Sorry, buddy.
Oopsie.
Okay, we gotta grab a bootleg headphones amongst the host of
electronics.
There's, oh my god, it's boats by boats.
I started zapping.
I couldn't help it.
I know there was more electricity things here.
wait there you go there you go now i can hack it sorry i
just blinded him temporarily wait where did he go
we're just hanging out don't mind me we just happened to
walking in the same direction the locals won't touch crypto
and we don't have a hundred grand let alone invite yeah i
blind him so he doesn't know i'm hacking so he doesn't know
i'm following him guys
Why?
I can't believe we're both heading to the same direction.
I'm walking around here surrounded by crates of guns,
shoulder-fired rockets, and enough explosives.
Wait, what?
Must be something I can use to convince her.
Oh my god, wait, how do...
How?
What I'm asking you is, I'm trying!
I'm trying!
No signal.
Get closer.
I have to...
Okay.
I'm trying!
Does anyone have a phone charger?
I'm looking for a phone charger!
Does anyone happen to have a phone charger?
Oh.
Oh my god, there's no phone chargers anywhere.
I have no battery!
Please, my phone uses the night lightning cable!
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I got it.
Alright.
Alright, it's okay, I can blind them.
Oh my god, where is it?
It's over here.
There's a desert.
How would they be able to charge?
Pinging the location of the call into your queue watch.
You're a star.
I know.
Always nice to be reminded.
All right.
See, easy.
Uh, comply.
Sorry about that.
I also need a pee, guys.
I'll be right back.
Move yourself.
Don't make me say it again.
Last chance.
Tourist.
How about I ruin those good looks?
Move away.
Keep trying, please.
How about I ruin those good looks?
Last chance, tourist.
Move away.
How about I ruin those good looks?
Keep trying, please.
Last chance, tourist.
Move away.
Keep trying, please.
How about I ruin those good moves?
Move away.
Last chance, tourist.
Keep trying, please.
Please.
How about I ruin those good news?
Move away.
Hey, tourist.
Good man.
Focus.
Oh, shit.
Mal, Quill, Mike, Anne, Zander, Neppers, Anne, Bight, Solid,
uh, Medi, Rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
So many last chat.
chances.
But that guy was hitting me up.
But I had to use the bathroom.
Sorry, I need to get by.
Wait, that guy has money.
Okay.
I can't poison him.
Like, what's the point?
Does nobody have a power bank?
He in the desert?
That guy was hitting on me.
I don't want me.
I don't pause the game when, like, I'm in, like, these types
of, like, types of genres, because then you guys can listen
to some funny dialogue while I'm in the bathroom.
Oh, my God.
Do they not?
Please!
I keep paying crypto!
Where's that over there?
Is that for my cup?
Lix?
I'll buy your power bank for five doge coins!
starts here come on people don't be shy step up and play a
game a track i'll play your game all right can't be too bad
no catch just guess correctly and win this jahari what many
people consider to be one of the most prized jewels here in
alif what's the catch you walk away with this your life
changes forever my friend oh my god i got close here and all
you have to do is guess No.
No.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I can't even play this.
I'm broke.
Oh, pause.
He gave me this whole spiel, and I don't have the money.
Watch it.
Lose once.
Okay, off-brand bootleg shoes.
Oh, my God.
There's Louis Bhutan.
There's Bikki.
They have Bikki here.
Guys.
Um.
What is it?
Let me go ahead and guess.
Do you want to sell me something, right?
Wrong.
I'll be fast.
Oh.
This is the only thing I can do to make money.
Trust me on that one.
Thanks for the tip.
Okay, solid.
Yeah, what around you know?
You know, I'm ready.
All in.
I'll do a gamba.
He said solo and win guys.
I trust him
He doesn't even have a dick
What is he gripping?
Whoa there Oh, donkeys some privacy.
I just wouldn't Where is it coming from?
I like how he stops peeing if I get too close.
Look at that He gets shy guys He gets nervous.
Personal space.
Just want to know if he's actually peeing or not.
That has to be someone we can put in there.
Are you sure he can't fight?
Or if he's pretending.
He's peeing on the job.
I need to know if it's real.
And we all know that stuff's only good for decreasing
engines.
What do we do?
Or if he's like using...
bathroom time on company time what do you want I want to
fight you look like you couldn't fight your way out of a wet
paper bag just point me in the direction of a bag listening
all by yourself hands up thank you thank you thank you talk
to the boss if you have people take bathroom breaks and
they're not actually using the bathroom is that the bar on
company time I'll go and have a word I gotta make sure okay
it's this way let me and I'll fight him so I so the boss
hired me to check on them to make sure people are actually
pissing where the fuck is the fight.
Jewel of Jahar, 3,500 to play.
But where is the...
There's the jewel, but I need to find like, how dare you
look at a guy to relieve himself?
I gotta make sure, you know?
They start scamming the company by pretending to piss.
Time is money, guys.
Okay.
I need like another zap, I need another zapper or something.
Anyway, inside.
Second floor.
Any word from the buyer?
No.
He's supposed to call Force Dead on the burner when he's at
the container yard.
He listened to him during the briefing earlier.
Okay, there's the Scorpius hide up.
What's this?
I need you to run a fair suite for me on a PMC outfit called
Scorpius.
I need to know why they're in town.
What are you up to?
Just pulling at the string.
How is this possible?
Oh, doink.
Watch your step in here, James.
I belong here.
Don't worry.
I'm part of the gang.
Wait, I should grab that power bank real fast.
Bye.
Doink.
Wait, there's something over here.
Don't worry.
It's Basim.
Everyone knows that shooting gallery this is rigged nobody's
ever been you should have known that cowboy yeah but I don't
miss like that know that that range let me see tempered with
the scope or maybe the target was waiting all right who is
that situation containing okay Containing the situation!
There we go.
We did it.
I told you, they called me the Contain Master.
Easy.
The situation has been contained.
Close.
What?
God got an update for you Scorpius comms are busy they're
moving stolen artwork looks like the last oh my god Picasso
according to chatter he's on route to my by I can grab
Picasso for my living room and then oh my god they have so
many power banks here oh
did you hear about the how the back rooms are do it did
really really well uh is that the yeah it's doing really
really well for critics and for viewers but like the the
thing i want to talk about is that they're trying 820 for
like the studio behind the back rooms by the director is
like 20 years old which is crazy but apparently like it's
testing really well with critics and test audiences and oh
sorry And, but the funny thing I want to talk about, about
the movie is that, uh, or the, the steel behind it, uh, the
production company that's releasing the film is also trying
to sell the original wallpaper replica of the original
backroom's wallpaper for $60 per four feet.
And the thing is, they got the wallpaper from this Twitter
user who let them photo scan his wallpaper because he has
the original wallpaper that was used at the office to make
the back rooms and everything where the back rooms came
from.
And he has the original wallpaper for it when he bought it
like all those years ago.
So the so A24 contacted him and asked if they could borrow
this wallpaper to use for the movie And if they could like
photo scan it and everything And he basically gave it to
them for free.
Yeah.
No, it's apparently not just a yellow wallpaper There's
symbols on it It's just that the wallpaper is yellowed out
from like old age and everything But and then he gave it to
them for free Because he lets them like photo scan and
everything so they could make like replicas of it wallpaper
for $60 per four feet and then the guy got really mad the
guy got really fucking mad because he was like bro I let you
use my wallpaper for free and now you're trying to profit
off of it like what the fuck dude like yeah it's pretty
messed up yeah of course he got mad he didn't get paid for
it he was just he just thought it was a cool opportunity
he's like yo of course you my wallpaper bro yeah to make it
more like authentic to the film yeah and he doesn't even get
a cut out of it i didn't i thought it was crazy like 60
dollars too for the wallpaper
just scary stories parents like to tell the local kids to
keep them in check now the ones about the girls yeah or he
just thought it'd be a cool like easter egg since he had the
original wallpaper And it's not even yellow.
It's like, apparently it's like white with like weird ass
like brown symbols on it.
He sees me over there.
Fucking idiot.
He's too busy.
Door the Explorer is on TV.
Oh, wait, no.
Evo is on TV right now.
He's got to watch it.
Sorry about that.
Oh, there's the hat.
They should walk.
Disguise leapt, blonde.
Urban design documentation plans to turn alpha into a
livable city.
I mean, he's doing pretty good.
Alright, now that I killed everybody, I found the perfect
disguise.
Oh my god, he got closer.
Wait, no, put the hat back on.
It's like, does it fit?
What?
No!
No.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Now I can just walk into them.
Okay, I need to go over there.
How do I get there?
Can I get there from here?
Oh, I can.
I mean, we should be cool.
now for now i've said it before and i will say it again we'd
be doing a big favor if we just put a bullet hey guys hey
are we not wait what but it's a perfect disguise did you not
see my hat oh shit but my hat's go
But what about my hat?
Oh, shit.
Okay, my hat did not...
Disguise could not be contained.
Oh, yeah.
Like, he remembers every fucking guard they hired.
Like, yeah.
As if he remembers every fucking guard.
There was, like, 40 of them.
Fight back.
I needed a good laugh.
I can only do so much.
Oh my god.
Alright, it's time to recontain the situation.
Oh, wait.
Oh, they stay dead.
Alright, at least they stay dead.
You know, I appreciate that.
The dead stays dead.
How was I supposed to know that?
Oh, shit.
I had to do this part again.
Parents like to tell the local kids to keep them in check.
Anyone there?
What are you doing?
Containing.
Sounds like fun.
Trust me.
They're not.
I'm speed running.
As long as he doesn't call.
Hello?
That's right.
What?
Hello, what?
Hello, that's right.
Call, decline.
There we go.
Let me put the hat back on.
We had to do that speed run for that.
Hello?
That's weird.
The call just went cold after that.
Maybe butt dial.
Oh, could have been a butt dial, bro.
Okay, we'll do this again.
You didn't see that.
That's fucking right.
Situation contained.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
All right, we got burner phone.
Container yard beside the anchor.
All right.
Burner phone acquired.
Turn on the radio.
Let's put on some jazz here.
Find containers.
I don't even know what my missions are anymore.
There's so many.
I've already lost track of the objective.
There's something here.
Oh, I can leave now.
Okay, I got everything.
All right, I need to find Container 76.
I grabbed a burner phone and some Intel on that deal.
By his name, Forster.
The exchange is supposed to take place at a container yard
here on the left.
You see if you can find anything else on him.
All right.
Who was that?
An old contact.
Fair enough.
You didn't happen to see a container yard anywhere around
here.
Behind the big anchor, I saw a cluster of them.
What are you up to?
Not your business.
Alright, let's go of your business.
I'm trying to earn $100,000 right now.
You said by any means possible.
Okay.
I'm still trying to see if I can find more.
I want to do that little.
I want to fight.
There's the container over there.
I need to make it enough so I can start shooting things.
Alright, there's the Scorpius.
Oh wait, what's this?
Now there's a man who looks like he enjoys blowing things
up.
What did it be?
I've got frags, gas grenades, and incendiaries.
On the lookout for M67 fragmentation grenades.
The Yankee special.
So the last few to some kids earlier.
Damn.
What?
I'm just kidding.
Oh okay, I was gonna say what kind of kid can...
What kind of kid would be able to...
Ford an m67 signal smoke grenades in red you know your stuff
come to think of it I did sell some to a gender reveal party
the other day oh shit I think I have some left back there
let me check what a party
won't be long incendiary need to be careful with that one
wait what can I steal from him.
Like here?
But there's nothing that's... Oh.
Are you sleeping?
It doesn't matter.
Alright.
Keeping on the job.
Eh.
What's moving?
Oh.
I'm okay.
I want to see if i could i just wanted to see if i could
take him down
what a great guard there's nothing around me i just gotta be
sure i'm a little paranoid right now 76 there she is oh my
god look at all that ram there okay everything is full all
right must have been the win
yes foster i'm here container 76.
how's all we with you in a moment but is that the mona lisa
just blew up they're onto you and headed your way right now
yeah they won't fight me in the container yes yes line your
head perfectly come on what
Line your head perfectly.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I'm safe here.
Okay, apparently not.
Damn right, I'm good.
What the fuck?
Oh, how did you get here?
Easy.
Situation contained.
Oh, hey.
You heard those gunshots earlier?
Sorry, I was watching a Michael Bay movie.
Sorry about the mess.
What happened?
Workplace disagreement.
Forced it, right?
Right.
This is Peter.
So, the painting I was promised.
Is it here?
It's back there.
Inside that container behind me.
Yeah, where I contained it.
Go ahead and have a look inside.
I should probably get going.
Six shots is all I need.
Your money.
Eta, please pay him.
Not Kigamba!
Alright.
Grab some of these extra guns.
Maybe I can sell them, too.
I like this.
I like the AR more, honestly.
Alright.
Maybe I can contain him.
Take it easy, will you?
Put you in that container.
I'm just surprised that these paintings and sculptures
didn't degrade.
Because you're not supposed to, like, it should be in, like,
a cool environment so the paint won't, like, melt.
What was it?
It's supposed to be in a nice environment so the paint
won't, like, decay.
for it to be here I don't think I don't think that's how you
preserve paintings and sculptures right where did he come
from oh my god he got closer how do I get out of it he came
out of here that's where the fucking dealer came from
this should definitely be stored in a better place oh my god
okay i gotta give him a little bit of food because he's not
gonna stop bothering me he fucking knows he
never does this he doesn't do this when i don't stream
that's the thing on rest days he doesn't do this he just
sleeps he knows he knows stream day is the perfect time to
get me oh he's like right on schedule.
I closed the deal and got what I needed.
What?
You had to be there.
It's that easy.
Got what I needed.
That's how the guards got.
Now I know the true meaning of suffering for your art.
Are you sure you're okay?
Ever better.
He knows this is the day.
These are the days when he gets to be fed whenever he wants.
And then he knows when I run out of food.
I think he can smell it.
He can smell like, oh, like, oh, she doesn't have any more
wet food now i'm pretty sure all right i want to do the
shooting range because he knows when to stop when i run out
literally when he gets the last bits of his food she just
stops barking
oh this is the shooting range now you smell the opportunity
all right now to have money it's time Just like a casino
royale.
Just you, that gun, and a big pile of cash.
All you have to do is hit all the targets.
That should be easy.
I'll play.
Do I need to use focus for this?
Okay.
Reload.
Found the perfect time to reload.
Where's nine and ten?
There, just in case.
I didn't know the timing for that.
Look at that.
Easy!
You think I hand anything over to you?
What do you mean I won fair and square?
Exactly.
Give me that money.
It really is one big beautiful prize.
All right.
Not bad, James.
Not bad at all.
All right.
I didn't know how fast the last two was, so I had to do
that.
All right.
Let's see.
What else is there?
There was the crypt track down, the crypto wallet, the
jewel.
I feel like if I do the jewel, the jihari is just instant.
I want to, okay, participate.
Wait, what about the crypto wallet?
Give me that crypto wallet money.
Give me that Dogecoin.
All right.
It's over there.
let's end it with some crypto we're gonna find a we're gonna
find the crypto wallet USB that's stuck in the landfill guys
the richest the richest wallet in the world we're gonna find
it I didn't ask for the finest coffee in a left I just asked
for a coffee you point what the hell my I know just
borrowing it for bit here crypto wallet any chance you can
crack it no signals too weak unless that's like images show
oh my god it's a gold finger golden finger that is the
starbucks that coffee bean is like is like 100 is like what
from 100 bc relax guys don't have to be so violent it's just
coffee all right let's see it i don't suppose you take
crypto i'm afraid i only deal in reality here
all right let's go let's go over there with my crypto
all right i want to go all the way up it's all the way over
there where is that is on the other side Yeah, it's on the
other side.
It's this way.
Yeah, the coffee's vintage.
What is it?
Let me go ahead and guess.
You want to sell me something, right?
Aruna is inside.
Good money to be made from the fights.
Oh, again?
You already told me that, bro.
really wants me to bet on Sala for some reason.
How do I get there?
Is that up top?
No, it's at the bottom.
I don't know where that place is.
This market is so confusing.
I'm like really lost right now.
There's no maps here.
Or it's like my little pamphlet book.
Yeah, because it's like right over there.
But how do I get over there?
I'm like, 10 grand.
Oh, it's over there.
It's the laundromat.
All right.
I don't think you'd be too happy.
I mean, like my Disneyland pamphlet.
I told you not to get involved with that.
They pulled a gun on wheels because I sunk the wheelie shot.
I don't like to be beaten.
I know that now.
The shot came in the way.
All right.
This is like a tourist trap.
This place.
should see this place money penny they've turned a shipwreck
into an apartment complex i've never seen anything like it
bavma's an ambitious man clearly this is prime beachfront
real estate all right let's see top 100 tourist spots on
pirate island true i mean you might as well go up top he's
like Yeah.
Is there anybody on the other side?
I don't think so.
What is he trying to fix?
Oh shit!
Oh he's trying to fix his gun.
Don't worry buddy, I'll do it for you.
After I'm done stealing.
So much for getting in and out.
When that bitch caught me, I knew things were going to get
messy.
Her face when I shot a dog.
Never had someone scream so loud.
Yeah, crew went quick.
Okay, we have an idea.
Someone jump over, but...
Don't take...
Pig.
Hey guys.
Oh shit.
Where's he?
Hey guys.
Oh!
Situation contained!
Call declined!
Sorry, I was a telemarketer.
Alright.
That was my plan, guys.
I think it went pretty smooth.
Ignore the spam call.
Sorry, butt dialed.
Oh, shit.
Hey, guys.
Excuse me.
Relax.
Why are you here?
What's your deal?
I saw someone run off.
Yeah.
Yeah, Green Beret.
Looked like a Scorpius foot soldier.
Shit.
Get moving.
Touch nothing.
Got it.
Who could have done that?
Anyway.
Situation contained!
There we go.
I gotta make it count.
Not only.
did I want to contain the situation I want to make it hurt
so don't see their inner circle before I betray them all no
one saw that coming I
have eyes on the relay tower all right making my way up to
it now okay keep me posted yeah I had to go this way it's
over there okay there's two guys over there it's not a waste
if i enjoyed it
hey guys what you need something easy now all right take it
easy you are not going anywhere
contain i'm on it
That's right!
Get out of here!
Okay, wait.
Let me grab you!
Alright.
Let me get...
Whoa.
Wait, I need...
I need to put you out!
Oh my god, wait, I can use him against...
Okay, here, get me...
Get over here.
And then...
Whoa.
Get over here.
Oh, whoa.
Oh shit.
Wait, no, you get over here.
Oh shit, okay, he doesn't let me...
Alright, I guess I'll just beat him up then.
No, you're not!
Get over here.
Let me grab you!
Oh my...
That's fucking right.
I could do it again.
And again.
And that's how you contain the situation.
there you go guys it's just that easy did I have to kill all
of them no did I enjoy it though whatever it is you're up to
maybe that's right I need what's on this wallet for what I'm
the container international terrorism of course just be
careful James but did I have fun though yes
All right.
All right, I got it.
We're only vulnerable.
Our path's only vulnerable after they attack.
Ah!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Wait, they...
Oh, shit.
Wait, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he contained me.
Oh, it's like, don't worry.
I got so much experience now.
I was like, him?
Powerful?
Bring it on!
I was like, oh shit, wait.
Oh my god, wait, he's level 99!
And I'm only level 1!
Alright, this time.
I got it.
That's right.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Okay, hold A and then space.
Okay.
Wait, I am holding it!
Oh my god!
Okay, this is a lot harder on mouse and keyboard than
sidestep.
Okay, here we go.
I'm the level one lackey.
Alright, this guy might be a little harder to contain, guys.
My back!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Whoa!
What the fuck?!
Wait.
I did it.
Situation contained.
Wait.
And that's how you do it, guys.
Just that easy.
That's not even that.
I didn't even break a sweat.
Okay, I guess.
That's how you do it.
Wow!
Look at that.
That's how you do it.
Too easy.
Give me a real challenge.
There it is.
The cell tower.
Couldn't contain the uncontainable, exactly.
And always do what you least expect.
Jump.
Just jump!
That's right.
Am I supposed to go this way?
Yeah.
Easy does it.
Not here?
It's like...
Wait, it's up top.
How do I get up there?
It's like here.
Alright?
A ruin automatic targeting.
communicator used by UK Ministry of Defense to communicate
coordinate the Royal Navy's Leah Polaris it's been submerged
for decades or is this just a little Easter egg oh it's up
here oh I see the arrows I see the yellow paint guys gravity
is just a suggestion at the tower perfect stay where you are
yeah all right grabbing my crypto I'm in Disabled the
password on the wallet, so you shouldn't have any trouble
accessing 50 grand on there.
Thanks money penny 50 grand.
Wait, I got it.
Okay I wonder if they let me do more afterwards.
Make a way to the auction entrance so we can pay up and get
inside All right, I get out of here
Hey, yes, hello ladies Way to the Copacabana, would it?
Oh I'll take that as a note Bye, ladies.
Goodbye, ladies.
I do want to do the...
Oh, I can't.
I can't do the Jewel of Jazeera.
Unlucky.
I want to do the Lady of Jazeera gems.
thing that looked fun i don't even remember where it was to
be fair maybe go see yeah but i don't know where it is i
don't remember this place is like i can still steal the
wallets though does they remember where it was located his
wife his Spanish one is ambitious ambition makes them
here yeah I can still rob them for money but like I still do
the jewel no that's not the jewel where is it the other way
oh my god I need to have the pamphlet I need my Disneyland
pamphlet so I know where I'm going I think it's here right
oh here here he is can i still do it no easy money easy win
he said easy money i can't do it that's unlucky not allowed
to do it i can't make more money i should be allowed to make
more money right after for fun but i
have the money you took your time got a little tied up
mingling with the locals pay the man bond here we are cash
and crypto i have my thanks you for your contribution All
right.
I'm
going to go inside.
Come to me, Luffy, the party king.
Yeah.
Where are these people here?
I'm a DJ, not a magician.
Stop pointing that gun at me.
What is a DJ doing here?
Something wrong?
Yeah, the decks are glitching.
Might be the speakers.
be the generator you might nice vacation for the rich while
i check the mixer chair wait why is he here you think these
idiots storm the cruise ship i was playing on threatened to
throw me overboard if i didn't come and spin at a birthday
party for some dude called nene they're crazy man oh the
classic wrong oh my god it's like taking them to saudi
arabia well not the kidnapping part but you know what i mean
yeah not the kidnapping part guys not the kidnapping part
you know how they got they got like Rinaldo to Saudi Arabia
the money with the money
just well disclosure I meant the traveling part
for legal reasons I did not mean the kidnapping or your
brains on the wall I should do it I turn the generator your
speaker was it hurry up well find out what color your
insides are I'm a DJ not a magician stop where's the other
wire go oh it's over here that's a no that is so far from
everything else speaker fuses completely burnt out A pair.
Where's the missing feet?
Oh, I guess this?
It's convenient that's right next to the speaker.
That's good.
Yeah, let's go!
DJ Gowden!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Let's go, guys.
The smoke machine fucking sucks.
But let's fucking go.
Oh, I'm a hero.
What are you doing?
Cooler, mate.
All right.
Follow me, please.
Look at that.
Add DJ to my resume.
James Bond, Super Spy, Super Riz, and Super DJ.
All your needs, my friend.
We have it.
If you want, we can help you over a throw a small country at
the right price.
DJ Bond.
Oh, would you look at that?
My kind of trouble.
She certainly is.
Holy shit.
Double O car.
That's double O.
Ring any bells, Greenway.
Keep talking like that.
You might wind up buried out here.
Worth it.
Hey, that guy's on his phone.
He's on his phone.
the job the scrolling please doom scrolling guys you got
pieces getting paid to doom scroll you think a place like
this would have been shut down by now control the chaos
control the flow bond keep warmer in play you always have
eyes on the game
what's that that drone is that military weapon Oh, next to
you.
Plant yourself here.
Take a look at those markings.
Serbian.
Oh, it is a drone.
That's why MI6 continues to let him operate.
Here we go.
Are we auctioning military weapons?
Are we Resident Evil?
So we can begin the auction.
While some of you have been here before, I see some fresh
faces amongst our buyers.
So, humor me while I go over our simple yet strict rules.
One.
All bids must pass through the polygraph.
Two.
Should you fail the polygraph, you will be removed from the
auction and forbidden to enter a lef again.
Well, at least we know what the polygraph is for.
Lastly, bids are bound by blood.
No retractions.
Now, a quick technical trial.
Place your hand on the polygraph machine in front of you.
The truth, if you please.
Miss Bahan.
I want to do that.
Just say, tell me, I need a drone.
Your turn, Mr. Konyavich.
I am Nikola Konyavich.
India.
China.
I represent the three storms, Klan.
Oh, yeah.
What is there?
Triads.
Go ahead, please, Mr. Easy now.
Call me James or Jet.
Thrilled to be here.
James will do.
And I'm thrilled to be here.
Dial it down.
Excellent.
Now that we've gotten the formalities out of the way, We
begin with an opening bid from our new guests.
Where are the Americans?
Do we not invite him?
Okay, one million.
One million US dollars.
A cash bid.
I'm afraid this isn't.
I believe we did invite him.
You have forfeited your opening position and the bid is now
free.
Safe passage to, from, and through all of our harbors.
No inspections, no questions.
Jeez.
To please an utter diplomatic cover.
Oh my God.
Private jet with armed escort for Bhavna.
Oh my bid looks like fucking shit now.
I can't compare.
Anyone care to counter Ms. Bachan's offer?
What the fuck?
Is useful?
but only temporary.
I offer permanence.
My organization will help fund and implement the next stage
of infrastructure in Aleph.
Oh!
What is...
What is Mr. Young gonna do?
Sabotage the next offer.
You read my mind.
I offer the next election in Mauritania.
seat will be delivered and gift wrapped i also offer four
european union ambassadors all of which have been
compromised the european union is it gonna start oh wait
we're hacking oh shit well that hasn't happened in quite
some time what is this something's wrong sorry he meant
three european union very surprised you may leave Time to
go, Mr. Leong.
Watch the suit.
Don't they touch all they put on.
Mr. Leong, you are making a scene.
We are done.
You have no idea what you're doing.
60-90.
We will not accept this.
There will be consequences.
Can't do that again.
Apologies for Mr. Leong's transgression.
Sometimes emotions do tend to...
Yeah, but then they could recognize Alpha as a country.
make a bid what the do i bid going twice anyone bond uh
scorpius and all affiliated organizations expunged from a
left now that is what a wonderful offer immunity open
although the bar has certainly been raised what is it called
political immunity Someone has something to offer.
From this day forward, every weapon used by my soldiers...
Artillery, drone, or artillery.
People love that.
Political immunity?
Unlimited volume.
Diplomatic immunity.
That's like a free gotcha pull.
But get a free jail card.
Do something to BT's offer.
Three decades of MI6 Intel.
what always do the unexpected right interesting how do you
propose delivering this intelligence by giving you him oh it
would appear the honeymoon is over one tx1000 marauder drone
sold to the boldest and newest buyer in the room that's
right now it's a hostage situation enjoy the rest of your
stay here in lf That's a little bit messed up.
Not going to lie.
Join me over here if you win.
Did I just sell a person?
Bond!
James Bond!
I just sold a man!
I just...
Yeah, you just did.
I'm going to do the unexpected.
But I got a new drone, though.
I got a new drone.
You have no power here.
Guys, I got cool new droid.
There are now another three of our agents in cold blood.
Bhavma broke the rules.
He's finished.
Your king's reign is over.
Nice to...
Guys, I got a sick-ass new droid.
You can stay with Bhavma.
But you'll go down with him and you'll watch as we turn this
whole place to dust.
Or...
That was very unexpected.
Next to Mr. Bond.
And our superiors will continue to turn a blind eye to all
that goes on here.
He truly is British.
Or don't you want to be king?
Throw in box seats at the menu and we have a deal.
Stratford End?
Best we can do.
Ah, we both know that's not true.
Fine.
Done.
Easy.
It appears you have some sway after all.
You coming?
He wants seats to Manchester United.
That's not where Ronaldo is.
Where the fuck?
A small slice of English civility here in the middle of the
desert.
That's where you'll find your friend.
How do we get to it?
By boat.
follow me this way gentlemen
he knows ball a fox always has more than one exit bond you
head out on foot so we can't slip out the back the power of
football just in time for world cup and the offer how do i
know you'll keep your word if there are no nasty surprises
the left will be yours by the weekend move out all right why
would you is he what the fuck oh he bugged out you go on
foot oh all right
get a move on
jesus where is he walking to
son i'm here talk to me ollie gave us 009's location headed
there on foot through what looks like a mid-shift point what
just happened
um okay he was done with your nonsense he has to find
gravity just so he did just so he didn't have to deal with
me taking the scenic route all right i'll update m i sold
him and he was done with my shit bond i just pulled
satellite imagery of the area there's a lot of heavy
activity on and off the water so watch your step in there
copy that thanks that's how much he hates me jesus is way
out
i'm on the water heading to the boat oh yeah i don't yeah
maybe like two feet above the water
That's what my bullshit, you learn to levitate.
Go in a hurry.
I need it to speed things up.
Look at these boys.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Not all of us can fucking levitate.
Girl number one, aspire crap.
Always do it.
Like walking away in the air.
Looking at this, I would say we've got about six or seven
hours before that swell hit us head on.
And we need to get everything off the water and processed
before that.
Tonight.
He's like, hurry up.
I'm sorry.
I wish I could also do it.
I wish I could also walk in air and defy gravity.
Well, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you to try and sell it.
He said duty unexpected.
Just following his word.
That's what three decades of MI6 info did.
That's just someone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got to thank you for the super chat.
Oh,
I could have lured him.
I didn't realize.
That's awkward.
No idea what happened there.
Bet Bavma was pleased.
Nice.
I gotta go this way anyway.
There's nobody in front of me.
I mean he's like, oh, pick up that.
Just in case I'm licensed to kill.
Maybe I just, maybe I just haven't been on the walk on water
class yet.
I just haven't passed my training.
Oh!
Greenway, how can we be sure Ali hasn't gone straight to
Babma?
He's walking us right into an ambush.
Ali wants a left.
He's been waiting for a chance like this.
Yeah, maybe that was a class last night.
The walk down water class.
I just want to be licensed to kill.
I could kill all these people right now.
Let's get back to work and keep our heads down until dark.
I could literally kill all of them right now.
Not bad.
You saw what happened to Aziz?
Let that be a warning to anyone who thinks they can steal
from Babma.
He has eyes everywhere.
Now get the rest of the queue.
I want this place closing in tonight.
And don't forget about the Englishman.
He's expecting a delivery.
Raj knows what he wants.
Speak to him if you have any questions.
You can't walk on there until you pass your driving test,
Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Don't have... I need a... I need a power bank.
That's looking right.
Contained.
Oh.
Is he coming over?
Does he also want to know?
So he's Jesus and tries to sell him out.
Does that make you do this?
Do this.
So I need the super chat.
Thank you.
How do I get across?
I definitely need this.
Where there it is.
Greenway.
Ali.
We're really going to give him control of a left.
The agency needs assets like Ali.
Let's say a terrorist group is planning an attack on British
soil.
Then let's say said group travels here to tool up for it.
With Ali sitting on the throne, we get a heads up.
It's not all black and white in this world, Bob.
There's a lot of gray.
Yeah.
What?
There you go.
Yeah.
It's another workplace accident, guys.
He must have been like, oh, not again.
Not another workplace accident.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's it?
Whoops.
All right.
Looks like he's taking a very heavy nap.
It's just a nap, guys.
All right, set the timer back to zero.
See, this is what they get for not getting the health
inspector, the safety inspector in here.
Just take a very heavy nap.
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is bad.
Unless...
What's going
on?
It's bad, guys.
It's in some kind of coma.
Oh, shit.
Not a coma.
Found him like this.
Scared the attacker off.
Chopping a green berry.
Yep.
Handle it.
You leave.
All right.
Yeah.
Unlucky that that happened, guys.
Yep.
Under...
That's so...
So unlucky.
All right.
Yeah, I don't know what happened.
Just...
He was just lying there!
Let's do that just for fun.
This guy has a little damage.
It's all the way over there.
This is all useless.
Whoever logged this didn't check what was inside.
I'm wasting my time here.
If Yusuf wants all of this done in time, he can't deal with
himself.
Who's over there?
What?
Okay, we just got to contain this situation.
Okay, there we go.
Situation contained.
He's got to casually contain it.
We gotta get there.
It's so far.
Okay, we gotta...
Oh, I guess I killed him for no...
Oh, wait, unless...
Alright, oh.
Tell me this is the greatest thing we've ever done.
What did I do here?
Oh, I could kill him.
Oh my god.
Hey guys, what happened?
Oh.
Oh shit!
I thought I could contain the situation!
Over there!
There we go.
Oh shit!
Into the water!
Get in the water!
Oh shit!
Oh my god, I gotta run!
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
Wait.
What?
What's that?
Whoa!
Shit!
it's time
all right finally nothing just containing all right there we
go there's no more pussy floating around
it's all right just a couple the people that want to kill me
everything is fine just the usual oh
there we go
it's fine there we go
god swap
oh god oh god i don't even know where I'm getting shot at
anymore.
There might be a lot of people shooting me.
Just a maybe.
Oh my god, he's all the way over there.
There we go.
Guys, that might be a mistake.
This might have been a mistake.
I did not realize there was a lot of people.
Oh.
There we go.
Where did he come from?
Oh my god.
They don't stop coming.
Who could have guessed?
Oh shit.
What a lineup.
Something like a little gunfight.
You know, to solve your problems.
Oh my god.
I was doing so well earlier, too.
You know, just the usual.
Holy shit.
Where are the others?
And
are in here!
Alright.
He gives me a little X when I kill him.
I don't know where that gunshot's coming from.
There's no way there's more coming out.
It's like, it's actually like unlimited.
Where am I getting shot at?
Oh my god, it's right behind me, isn't he?
Where is he?
There we go.
I swear to God, there's no way this is unlimited goons.
There has to be an end.
There has to be an end of all these goons.
Oh my god, there he is.
Alright, one more.
What the fuck?
We've lost him.
Okay, one.
Wait, that might be the last one.
Look at me!
Did I do it?
Why is there still boss music?
Get it, Dragon!
Wait, there's like four of them.
That has, those three have to be the last one.
He's on a killing spree!
That's right!
I won't stop until you're all dead!
There might They actually might be unlimited Wait, unless
These might be the last ones
Come on, poke your head Come on, poke it There we go Okay,
there's one over There Where is he hiding?
I see you Oh my god, he's just trying to hot cap on that
wall because he thinks that's gonna save him I got him do
you though do you oh wait I'm a wait give me a sec I'll come
back and kill you later there we go
he's the last one
situation contained the little he the big act that you like
readjusted his bring the objective is the option of it's all
about the kills yes it's about the KDA and that's how you do
it baby
that's how you do it all right let's now we can just
casually walk through Who needs gadgets, guys?
Nobody will notice if there's no one to notice.
A license to KDA.
Oh, now I get the sniper.
Look at that.
Hey, Doki, have you seen my friend?
They went to stop some guy at a warehouse.
What is your position?
Oh, I think he went to go to Dairy Queen.
Just missed him.
What kind of friend wouldn't invite you to Dairy Queen with
him?
Bro, that's fucked.
I can't believe it.
Didn't think about inviting you, Quail.
What a bad friend.
Really?
Him and his...
Him, he left with a group of other people.
Did he not invite you?
There I ask how it's going, Greenway.
I don't think he likes me.
No grow on him.
been through a lot nobody could have predicted what would
happen back in slovakia greenway did he told us 009 couldn't
be trusted and we didn't listen then you work with greenway
to bring 009 in roger that all right i'm on board almost
there easy does it all right guys it's still stuff when
there's no way exactly i mean i did stuff in the beginning
guys i gave it a shot and then i shot him You can't say that
I didn't try.
I made an attempt.
Another booby trap here.
Alright, we can disarm that booby trap.
We can go through here.
And I disarm this booby trap.
So I can disarm this.
booby trap and then I disarm this booby trap
cabin straight ahead whoa I'm more worried about the ones we
can't see break a beam and trigger those mines Beckett will
be scraping you off the deck any idea how to disarm negative
but lasers react to particles in the air that should help
you circumvent them and not get blown up noted meet you at
the cabin door all right
okay whoa that's not fair how the do i i can't jump over
that how do i get past that
okay and there's one over there too like all Oh, all right.
I still can't get past that, though.
There's one over here.
Oh, this is tough.
This is scary.
Just forward here.
Mysterious opponent.
No, I'm not allowed to...
Oh, wait.
Can I use my gun for it?
I don't know.
No, I can't.
it won't let me aim can i vote over it let me see oh i can
okay that's good i was worried i can't do that bond still
here take it nice and slow okay oh that's cool i like that
that's a very interesting mechanic
Okay, nice.
And they're way past.
I don't know if I get past here, though.
Oh.
There we go.
Welcome to the jungle.
Looks just like his allotment back in Richmond.
What the fuck?
all right we made it let's find out get the door it's over
here though all right let's open the door knock knock it's
me bond
if it comes to it do not hesitate to put him down on you how
did he get there he walked on the wall he levitated that's
how i'm i missed a class for it oh Oh, is that double nine?
Is he dead already?
All clear.
You forgot he could walk on Wani.
Christ.
Gutshaw.
Bleed out slowly while they worked him over.
I missed class for it.
Because I wanted to go to the club.
I was trying to make a point.
There's something in his mouth.
Is that diamonds?
Diamonds?
Red diamonds?
Oh, you must have really rubbed someone up the wrong way.
Take a look around.
See if we can figure out what transpired between 009 and his
uninvited house guests.
Okay.
Place in side bicycles after they really murdered him.
How did you know the diamonds were fake?
The circular dot reflected inside the stone.
It's a dead giveaway.
Diamonds aren't even worth shit anyway.
You'll master it with time and experience you were thinking
master fucking walking on water Maybe just teach me that
instead over like I said he really pissed someone off
They're like that's a better skill than fucking diamonds All
those people Damn you Beckett What were you looking at?
What was he looking at?
Oh, hey, there's a guy over there.
The fuck?
State of the art triggering mechanism.
Could have gotten the materials here.
Nothing.
Oh.
Why would he hide out here in a left?
Align himself with Bhavma.
Become untouchable.
Nobody's untouchable.
See anything else.
Just the ship.
Yeah, I was going to say, why is that?
God, just fishing.
What was just chilling out there?
There's nothing else.
There's just some guy on the boat.
Oh, maybe that?
Ha ha ha!
There's anything else to look at.
This pirate ship?
But you don't think there is anything else to look at.
Yeah, I think that's it.
Just wanted to be sure.
Better stuff.
Blueprints of the Grand Carpathian.
He knew where to place the bombs.
And inflict maximum damage.
That's his plan.
What's this?
Yesterday's UK newspapers.
He was keeping up with things.
There was a Simba.
What is there?
This is the closest I can get.
I don't...
Yeah, it has nothing to do with anything.
It's this random dude fucking fishing, though.
Shanghai shipment.
This one will be sure I'm not missing anything.
Is it really just that boat?
I guess it was.
Same bomb materials I saw in Slovakia.
More evidence to support his lunatic agenda.
Eh.
Someone certainly had it in for the agency.
I know the names of the WL recruits, Monro.
Oh, right.
My name is there.
I'm included.
See, I'm part of the gang.
Yeah.
It thinks I'm...
I'm an agent too.
Recent surveillance of Greenway.
Look at that.
Gotta see.
I'm also part of the gang.
Yay!
Take a look at this.
What am I looking at?
On the floor.
The fuck?
Greenway, this picture.
You're in it.
There's a note.
It says...
Remember this.
That was Operation Spyglass.
Operation Spyglass.
What are that?
Part of the team.
I knew it.
I'm included.
That can't be a coincidence.
So you knew 009.
I thought I did.
I'm not a diversity hire.
Hey, Nazar.
No.
We have everything we need.
Let's go.
I think he wants us to see something.
The telescope.
I need to go and take a look.
Hey.
All right, look at that.
just like to be included you know even if it's a hit list at
least he thinks at least he thinks I'm also in I'm I'm part
of the team you know holy
shit liar why murderer who's he safe to say he had a bit of
a thing for you oh he did not like him
HQ should we be worried about this maybe keep looking the
telescope didn't you want to take a look what the fuck oh
they called em a liar
liar why it looks as though things were moved around he is
obsessed in the middle of redecorating or maybe it was his
killer or killers terminated who is he he's like who is this
guy he thinks he's part of the team thought i was like i
thought i was part of the team who is he yeah what do you
call this who invited this guy who just you mega loved me
yeah they're like oh my god am i six standards high
standards have lowered would have fucking invited this poor
man he's so broke god i would invite this peasant to be part
of the team
the other recruits monroe bright nash singing kingsley looks
like he was following the rebooted double o program of
course he was he had eyes on the apartment he had eyes
everywhere from the look of him i'm like haru from around
high school host club he's just like what the is he a make a
wish kid who invited this guy over all
right let's look at the telescope bro think he's part of the
team yeah i've been so thinking the super chat thank you
thank you
i thought i was important i was but i'm on the hit list
though i'm on the hit list i'm Why not that important?
But bro, put me on the hit list.
I was happy for like one second.
Bingo.
I'm marking on the back of this picture of you and him.
Matches the logo on that ship out there.
That's where he wants us to go.
He's dead, Bond.
His own men killed him because he got greedy.
And the diversity hit.
going sight-seeing in the asshole of nowhere only you would
have made the connection to operation spyglass dead as he is
he's telling us something we'll never know if we don't take
a look all right fine but don't be surprised if this is
nothing more than a ruse to finish off what he started just
so he knows that he's inclusive you know he's like yeah i
don't play favorites guys
Oh, I guess it was in housekeeping.
I
guess it was in housekeeping.
Oh, hey, crocodiles.
I am sometimes asked.
Bofma, how is it that you hear every whisper in every corner
of Aleph?
And I answer.
I built Aleph with my...
How did he know?
I was a spy.
I thought I killed everybody.
Is it all the bodies I left on that ship?
No, it can't be.
Do you think he found the 200 men I just killed?
No, right?
If an infection is left untreated, the body can become
rotten.
Sicken and die.
It can't be the corpses.
That infection?
Greed.
In Bakar Ali, once so loyal, greed grew unchecked.
I thought they're buddies.
A cancer that threatened to weaken Aleph.
Endangering all of us.
Why contain a situation?
Exactly.
Is it contained?
Cancer, if caught early, can be cured.
Am I gonna start shooting crocodiles?
Or in our case, cut out and start.
served on a platter.
Oh, shit.
Easy girls.
Plenty of meat for everyone.
Girls.
Of course.
Oh, that's what he means by girls.
Our old friend was just the appetizer.
That's who he was talking about.
Oh, and his jacket!
It's like chocolate, sorry, chocolate.
I think not Now You die He's like the crocodile Hunter Or
the crocodile man
Alright it's time to punch A sharp I keep saying sharp A
bargain I'm afraid this is all a big misunderstanding
Beckett was dead when we found him on the boat Lies You got
greedy They always do It was his own men who cut him down i
find that very hard to believe greenway back me up here oh
he has not oh he's still now wait
i say i was thinking about threatening them uh i'll
negotiate i i can do it myself
mmi6 pay up to help their agents had you not killed my
friend he would laugh at your naivete and besides i don't
need your blood money he has blood money my girls on the
other hand they have only had their appetizers which makes
you two the main course drop them and let us watch the sands
run red oh maybe i should have waked him don't worry
greenway what the hell have you gotten us into what do you
mean me thinking think faster harmony okay maybe i should
have woke him up i thought i got this guys i thought i had
it under control
that if this is an attempt at deceiving me i will erase your
entire bloodline i thought i had it under control i thought
i didn't need help one more time I'm an independent spy!
We know where she is.
We have a location.
Oh, that's a sister.
Now!
That's a sister.
I think I had it under control, guys.
I did not meet Greenway.
I'll be honest.
This turn of events is...
I just thought... I felt sorry for Greenway for being out.
I thought, you know, I might as well give him some credit.
...to my bodyguard, Nini.
is a special day it's her birthday well let me guess me
isn't too happy with us she is most displeased oh and before
you leave I would suggest checking in and around your seats
for oh my god they've had a bomb what kind the scorpion kind
uh she's a thing for them hell has no fury like a woman
scorned for Land Rover
must be going.
Bye-bye.
I hope you two find what you're looking for.
Hey, bye-bye.
Are we not going to check for scorpions?
He did say there were scorpions.
Alright, we're going to drive to the wreck now.
Interesting turn of events.
Wouldn't you agree?
Yeah, that's one way to put it.
I guess we're going to see if there's a little surprise for
us.
Right.
I'll get out of jail card.
What a coincidence.
You just happen to know.
If there's something you want to get off your chest, now's
the time.
Why didn't we go directly to Babma with the information we
had on the system?
Yeah.
Why wait until the very last second to play your hand back
there?
We do not give up valuable information if we can get what we
want.
I mean, that's true.
Don't expose all your cards at the start.
In the handbook.
Front and center.
What happened between you and 009?
Nightfall.
When Thayer was first instated, they discovered a mole ring
at the top of British intelligence.
Three highly decorated 00 agents, including 009.
I was tasked with tracking them down and neutral.
There's a mole.
That's the job, Bond.
What if Greenway was the mole?
The entire time?
I see you two friends.
before operation nightfall that's why oh my god because you
know how it says liar that's what it looked like in the
picture of the two of you it was like liar traitor what a
greenway was the ball orders are orders bomb besides we
stopped being friends the moment the man betrayed the crown
or like the or like whatever the guy that was the ai guy the
ai guy purposely make them that the double O's were
traitors.
Double O'9 tagged M as a liar.
What was, what did they, what did he wrote for Greenway?
I forgot.
I just remember the liar part for M.
What happened to the other two agents?
Terminated?
Didn't make a difference either.
Because when Double O'9 got away, they just buried the case.
Shutter the double O branch.
jockey a desk for the last 10 years as a reminder of my
failure but then m came along and revived the double o
program right her and the pm much to the chagrin of bright
and now here we are in the middle of the desert chasing
clues on the side of a shipwreck from a dead traitor while
we wait for the other shoe to draw It's pretty suspicious.
We're out of this way.
Those blonde twins.
Have you ever come across them before?
No.
But one hears stories.
Nico and Tero murder.
Supo, the Finnish security service, calls them the Great
Whites.
The hair?
That, and because they're silent killers.
Frankly, I'm amazed you survived the fight.
Next time, I'll finish it.
Love, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
But they just popped in.
Yeah, we met the bond, girl.
Yeah, we did.
But we only saw her once.
See if you can find a way to get us across.
That was my plan.
Alright, let's see.
I mean, I assume we have to climb this.
This game is so interesting.
I love how the story is so far.
Like, we're all piecing it together, slowly.
One down, one to go.
Whoops.
Alright, we're gonna go all the way down to the other pipe.
I've never played uncharted.
My dad has.
I remember watching my dad play uncharted, but I've never
played uncharted myself.
Well, she's not actually French.
She just pretended to be French.
So there's still hope for her.
We can still...
We can still save her.
We can...
We can still fix her.
Thank good.
It's not a deal breaker, guys.
Let's push on.
Ah, we, we.
Viva la bon, mademoiselle.
Love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, we banged the secretary too.
My man!
There's an entrance over there.
Right with you.
Listen, if Beckett rigged his boat, he'll have done the same
thing here.
Okay.
That means a pod in my man.
What is that?
war shorthand for marking safe rooms in the field what's it
doing here he wants us to see something
that i see it there's a giant a
much thank you for the super chat thank you thank you loving
you series so far i only mainly got your bond knowledge from
fanfics but what was your first bond film casino royale
that's the first Craig, right?
Whichever was the first film from Daniel Craig.
But I remember Casino Royale the most.
He was my first James Bond.
I watched a lot of other spy films, though.
Like, Man from Uncle and Kingsman.
And watch your step.
Don't worry, I've got parkour!
But I saw Casino Royale in theaters.
But my parents another booby trap here
and then what was that oh my god what was that song the it
was a parody oh I was obsessed with this one song that was
like a parody of James Bond and it was like what if James
Bond like what if the villain was gay for James Bond like
that was the whole music video but the song fucking slapped
though bunny thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you I'm trying to remember what it's called I was obsessed
with that song for the longest time and the music video was
really, I really liked the music video too.
Genghis Khan, yes!
That is, it's a really good song.
It's a really good song.
Genghis Khan.
It's, oh yeah, now I want to play it.
I need to, okay, I won't play it on stream but I'll listen
it to it right now.
But I mean, oh yeah, I watched Austin Powers too.
And Genghis Khan.
It's really good.
But the whole, the music is just like What if, what if the
villain was in love with James Bond?
And that's why he does all these things.
Oh, and also, um...
Bantana.
Bant.
Are you there?
Where the hell have you been?
Are you going?
Just bring it around.
About to be fed to a pit of crocodiles by Babma after we
found Boathouse.
He's dead.
Yeah, very much so.
I'm going to...
Yeah.
Oh my god, he's singing with me.
Let's see what these do.
here we go he's doing the well with me what no no no i'm i'm
grooving right now i'm jiving not going that way i'm gonna
be with gangas con no one about you no one about nobody else
but me but nobody else but me gonna kill a bit gang is gone
Nobody else but me Nobody else but me
He's being a backup dancer
I'll get that open on my own All right, I need greenway to
help me What's this
I make this jump.
Nope, I can't.
Probably another one of these traps.
Well, if it is, at least we get to go out together with a
bang.
Oh.
I don't know myself.
No, I don't know myself.
I'm a little bit Genghis Khan.
Oh, there it is.
Me.
But nobody else but me.
I'm gonna get a little bit Genghis Khan.
It's such a good song.
I literally listened to that song on repeat for like two to
three weeks.
I was so obsessed.
He has like one arm.
How the fuck is he gonna help me?
I expect you to stream.
I mean, die.
the super chat thank you thank you doesn't change the fact
that he blew up a hotel killing our people your friends
turned his back on king and country oh no no no no
damn that's a strong-ass shoulder
no thank you for the super chat thank you thank you we need
to get you to sing the gold finger theme song for us one day
that would be an awesome concert think of the super chat
they could think i never heard of that song before i'm right
here listening to it after take a look through those crates
man puts doomsday preppers to shame on
can't be here oh i get a little bit gang is gone don't want
to go
Everyone else but me.
Oh, I get a little bit Genghis Khan.
Alright.
Let's see.
Reloading press.
Oh, ammo reloader.
Yeah.
He was.
You don't stockpile like this unless you know something's
coming.
What the fuck who was gonna get him?
Trauma kits, chest seals, wound dressing.
Somebody was gonna get him.
Unless he's either he knows something was up or he's schizo.
Oh yeah, you guys finally met my friend who actually has
schizophrenia.
See, I told you, he's like such a chill guy.
It was during Apex.
For those who don't know, it was during our Twitch stream
while I was playing Apex.
Catches on either side.
Now turn them until they're horizontal at the same time.
And open it?
Hey, presto.
We're not dead.
we did it it was a 50 50 chance i take my odds here's your
evidence green day
what is it 2009 looks like he wasn't the culprit he was the
target
what was that it's the other shoe we were followed who
though oh shit oh of course we gave the only evidence to
greenway wouldn't be funny if he suddenly loses the evidence
during this entire fight what an odd coincidence that he was
the one that has the evidence say much yeah they're here for
the case and we let them straight to him
Oh, where is he?
I need to reload.
Oh my god, there's people on my side.
Of course there's people on my side.
Oh no, I don't have it.
Pick it up!
Fuck that's a shotgun!
Alright.
Where could he be?
Yeah, where did he go?
Honestly.
There we go.
You though?
Oh shit!
There we go, now I got him.
Hey everybody?
Oh, they're coming in.
Oh wow, okay.
To be fair, I expected a little more.
I will say I did expect a little more.
We gotta get ammo real quick.
Can you?
Can you peek me?
Come on.
I'll let you challenge me.
It's do or die.
It's just you and me.
Guess not.
die do what you mean that okay it's over there yep you lost
sight of me guys there we go oh he's so lucky I need your
gun where did you drop it all right there it is I don't
think he did see me.
Oh, he's dead.
All right.
I guess it was do or die, but for him.
Okay, bad news.
Yeah?
See, this is why I play on mouse and keyboard.
Go on.
Greenway what's the plan yeah same kid from tobacco I'm
supposed to like listen anyway this time we'll get what we
came for the package package negative because the old boy
made up with it before we could get to him tell me something
I don't know mate doubtful it's a wide-open space but he's
British and I've got the advantage from up here i shoot him
on the foot listen there's somewhere in this wreck we'll
find him sooner or later i thought but he's british and he's
like yeah i love you too i mean i mean uh bye all right oh
sorry i didn't realize everybody was gonna whoops that's an
oopsie
Whoops.
I didn't realize that meant...
Wait, where are they?
That's my bad.
I really want to shoot him on the foot.
I couldn't help it.
Guys, he was so shootable!
I couldn't help it!
He was so vulnerable!
I work in progress.
Oh, this is bad.
Uh...
I couldn't help it!
Oh, fuck.
Fuck this guy, though.
That guy had so much armor.
It wasn't fair.
There we go.
That should be all of them.
I couldn't help it, guys.
His feet was just out there.
And you want me to not shoot his foot?
It was so vulnerable.
Then you get to sit there for free.
And you expect me to not shoot it?
All right, I got to go down.
Yeah?
See.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
That's my bad.
I didn't realize they were patrolling.
There we go.
All right.
It's fine.
Oh, nice.
I actually needed that.
I wonder who.
Am I?
He's reloading.
Am I, though?
Maybe you're... Oh, wait.
I am reloading.
Nice catch.
Alright.
It was after I killed him, though.
Yeah, I was going to reload, but only...
after I kill you.
He counted my bullets wrong.
That was his first mistake.
And grab this.
I like how you kick.
That's like a kickflip with it too.
Look at this.
Whoop.
There you go.
A little kickflip.
I know there's more of these pistols.
I'm going to grab more of it.
Yeah, I know there's like a lot of ammo for this one.
Alright.
I know I look so cool.
Radical, bro.
He's so cool.
I don't need to use gadgets.
I'm...
Okay.
He's standing the line for me.
please keep standing in the line it's very helpful
amazing mercenaries there wow look at all these explosive
around me i have only i could use them only
oh okay that actually hit me All right.
There we go.
Yeah, he's over there.
He was over there.
Well, look at all these explosives that I could use to help
me in the fight.
But why do that when I can just...
shoot them now.
Why?
Why put all that trouble?
Okay, this is one shots.
Okay.
When they just lined their heads.
Didn't waste any gas, guys.
Look!
The world!
Gas prices are going up right now.
I gotta not waste that.
Try to be conservative with oil and gas prices.
Oh, shit.
It's the twins.
I said four.
Brace yourself.
They should have just let me kept shooting.
I could have ended those twins in, like, five seconds.
Yeah, I'm thinking about the economy right now, dragons.
I could always buy more ammo, but the earth is running out
of oil.
Oh no.
No, the evidence!
Oh, how convenient.
How fucking convenient.
They destroyed the evidence.
Explosive stuff.
How convenient.
Oh, it's not my one shotgun.
It's not the same.
Do I not have my pistol?
I don't have my pistol either.
This is bad.
Oh my god, you should give me your gun I gotta make every
shot count
Tell me you have another gun Yeah, please tell me you have
another gun Give me your pistol I gotta make every shot
count Yeah, green way You're so helpful right now Hold out,
you need another Here Oh my god, give me there we go
oh shit no I have so much ammo right now does he have
another one not true I have 20 more bags and you lost words
no not nothing not even a good job bond you would have made
a great double oh nothing springs to mind what the fuck of
course not oh oh yeah okay literally did all the shooting
there can't even be like good job oh my god the pirate king
it's like a fucking it's like a dad he's like doesn't even
say doesn't even say he's proud of me Like a real father.
Lolly, think he was super chuffed.
Thank you, thank you.
Those brits must have been louder because they're World War
I for bears out of machine gunness.
Well, that's that.
Well, what happened?
Well, what do you think happened?
Parking saved us.
His muscle killed him.
End of story.
Well, he said it wasn't him.
He can't be serious after what we found.
Yeah.
We have no evidence, Bond.
M needs an open and shut case.
so what's our next move can't you just say you're proud of
me it's the go home bomb he's just like you i guess you did
all right of course you're not gonna tell her about what we
found of course greenway i bet you're the one that tipped
them off it's not like that or thea thea tipped them off or
a greenway i don't know i don't trust greenway
Something suss about him you don't have to like them You can
drop me in theater AI guys.
Yeah, I know where it is You realize the mercenaries I
fought at the airfield will not double our nine's men They
were there to intercept him and they would have if I hadn't
gotten in the way Somehow these people beat us to him twice
and we are the only ones who believe they even exist take a
breath Drive us what did I do wrong inside it will eat you
alive Unbelievable.
I'm serious.
Get out of town for a few days.
I believe there's Travis's.
In other words, just do nothing.
More has been asked of lesser men.
This is me.
Try to get some sleep.
I am driving on the right, on the right side of the road.
It's not my fault they built the roads differently.
They built, it's not my fault they built the roads wrong.
I figured you'd be drowning your sorrows right about now who
says I'm not I know what a pub sounds like James in fact I'm
on my way to one right now got a date going out we just put
three oh my god wait the driver's this actually forces me
like it actually turns for you watch this I'm going head
straight watch this it's actually an auto drive car aren't
idiots james we managed just fine before you came along you
sound like greenway just go home go for a run shake it off
tomorrow's a new day it's dokey proof good luck on your huh
why she hanged up on me
i think i was doing all right
they dokey proofed it Oh, it's Monroe's stuff.
Do you think Cassie is here?
Oh, is she doing therapy?
Is it on other...
Oh, Cressy?
The merchant relief packages.
She's doing retail therapy.
Oh, God, is his shoes.
I won't give dad the rest of his food.
It's time, anyway.
I gave him the rest of the food.
I can't believe it.
It's practically a self-driving car.
It overrides me.
I couldn't face staying in the apartment any longer than I
had to.
Someone will come by and pick up the rest of my things in a
couple of days.
There are just too many reminders of...
I'm alone now.
The gang's all broken up.
I'm getting out of London for a little while.
I'm going to stay with Mother at the Summer House in Almalfi
when I figure out what's next for me.
that none of what happened in Savakia, not one single Iota
was your fault.
If Monroe were here, he would tell you the same.
You saved my life.
And for that, I am forever grateful.
Take care of yourself, and please don't be a stranger.
I mean that, James.
Cresada.
And then we never hear from them again.
The gang is all broken up.
My found families gone.
I'm an orphan and then she put up her fucking painting
before she left that bitch um Monroe and I fucking picked
the poster before she left like oh okay fine whatever
whatever could her Monroe's go to this is her highlighted
and Because I was like, can't wait to see my sick-ass
poster!
Well, Monroe ain't around anymore.
You're not Christina's favorite mug pop for her by Monroe.
You're a knockout.
I can't believe it.
Now I'm an orphan all over again.
Can't even have a sick-ass poster.
you're in the kitchen movie marathon fly at the crescendus
and monroe's final date oh
everything reminds what is that is that carrot on the stick
okay who's this is monrose at least it's not leg day all
right that's good hangman Piss.
Poison tip umbrella.
Oh, poison tip umbrella.
I'm sorry, I don't know why I thought it was piss.
Poison tip umbrella.
Of course.
It's so obvious.
Alright, unfinished car came played before leaving for
Slovakia.
Oh my god, it's like a little time capsule.
I'll have a drink.
Everything was left untouched before.
we left.
Pour one out for Monroe.
That's what's called, right?
When you left a place before all the shit happens, the
little time capsule, the self-contained area before the shit
dropped.
Before everything.
Monroe's pick up dry sleeping Thursday.
Monroe, stop ordering shoes.
Thank you.
Ronro clean up your dog, get milk.
Your mom called, your mom called again.
Cryptography, someone grabbed.
Yeah.
Where everything blew up.
Where everything changed.
Ronro's manual toothbrush and straight razor.
My God, everything reminds me of him.
the greatest value is that of carelessness the next greatest
vice is that of vanity wait what does that say no one is
above suspicions we live by deceiving others
double seven
on its own design very true of character no green waste nice
Monomic game of MI6 Monomeran game ideal for remembering,
proving, understanding difficult concepts and mastering new
learning strategies.
Simply pick a card, memorize the objects on it, then write
down the ones you remembered.
All right.
Write lightly.
The blank page beneath can be read.
The rules of engagement.
In case of being followed, dump all traceable evidence.
I'll miss him, guys.
Never be the same.
Or bromance.
God.
Oh, stop.
Oh, Monroe, stop ordering shoes.
It's his money.
A silver brush blind to God's late mother.
Don't forget to clear his browser history.
That's what we would have wanted.
Game here bought a Valentine's gift from Monroe and Chris
Crescita.
That's not mine.
I know for a fact that's not mine.
A no-nonsense guide on how to tie the 50-plus most practical
rope knots.
My god, am I a fucking freak about ropes and knots?
a total mythology and other fields of interest oh my god
bond you freak a photo of young James Bond his parents
Andrew Monique playing cards on a night before their death
oh yeah you can't have bondage without bond that's true
there's no bondage without bond to whom it may concern
they're gone because of my mistakes i could have stopped it
but i failed it should have been me james bond did i write
that this can't be good oh i did not write that oh no i was
like
that cannot be good i was like i don't think i wrote that Oh
shit!
I was like, there's someone here, isn't there?
How dare you!
This is Monroe's place!
How fucking dare you!
Oh my god, my PC!
Oh my god!
You owe me a new 60-80!
Okay.
Do that again.
That's right, do that again.
Oh, right.
Never mind.
I'm done playing with you.
There we go.
Not my gaming rig.
How dare you desecrate?
The walls he's in.
The mark has entered the building.
He brought a friend.
How dare you?
But he's gone.
Oh, there he is.
How?
Fucking dare you my PC My my 60 90 See oh wait that's my
chair wait that's the key Hermit Miller my key my Hermit
Miller Logitech chair It's the exact one I have The M, I
have the exact chair.
This is actually, he is a gamer.
He is actually a gamer.
Yeah, it's the Logitech.
It's the Logitech.
See, it has the Logitech logo right here.
Like, right there.
James Bond's a gamer.
I wonder what games he plays.
Because he could have got any other Herman Miller.
But yeah, he got the Logitech one.
I didn't realize
Under what kind of gamer he is Yeah, but what competitive
game does he play?
Took you long enough Did the little run give you a run for
your money?
Did you say anything else?
Oh, shit I thought you would say something else, but I guess
not That's fucking right!
How dare you!
How do you know about Mauritania?
How dare you desecrate this place?
This is a sacred place!
It's fucking right!
For Monroe!
Actually, I wanted to take him to the painting, but I
couldn't.
He kept running off.
Who do you work for?
Now talk.
Take the shot.
Oh, I mean, he did take the shot.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ!
There we go.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay right now.
There we go.
Alright.
Thank god he's not as good at shooting as me.
Thank god.
all right just go home go for a run shake it off she said
see oh i don't think i can use yeah she distracted
all right i go this way all right it's okay everything is
fine It's really bad at shooting.
Luckily.
Oh, I don't have enough energy for it.
I'm not vaulted over the...
Oh, I have to vault from here.
That's not good.
Alright.
Let's see.
There we go.
Is there anything else I can use?
Okay.
All right.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of shots.
Wait, it's him.
It's the twin.
Okay.
No, I can't use anything else.
I just got what, run for it.
I just got to book it.
And hope for the best.
I don't have anything else to use.
There you go.
Jump!
okay everything's fine you can't shoot through that luckily
you can't shoot through that i'm gonna be climbing that
thing aren't i yeah
is there anything i can use i don't use that what am i
climbing Jump!
KADAM!
Jump!
Faster, James.
Alright.
Go as fast as I can!
Okay.
Nice.
You guys pretty bad at sniping, I will say.
It's definitely...
It's definitely an intern or something.
Don't worry.
I'm very slowly heading there.
He definitely lied on his resume He either lied on his
resume or his first day on the job Not doing so well
He's like a graphic designer or something He's like,
alright, we're gonna need you to kill a guy
We're gonna need you to...
Here's a sniper Surely you've used one before, right?
He's like, yeah Oh,
shit!
Well, he's like, no body.
Surely he's dead.
That's how it goes, right?
He must have hit the concrete so hard.
His entire body just combusted and scattered everywhere.
And the blood dried up.
From the heat of the force.
Yeah.
What did he try to look for after missing 500 shots?
He was like, aura.
At the apartment.
I took his phone.
I need you to trace a text.
What?
I can't.
He's like, yeah, he's like, he's, and you're suspended.
His aura maxing.
Go through the proper channels.
It's the twins.
We don't have time for protocol.
The Murtos.
Operating in central London.
And he's aura farming.
If I lose the trail, we'll never know who they're working
for.
Please, Money Penny.
She hasn't had a date in so long.
Let her date.
Are you sure this is the place?
The signal's coming from inside the works and arts museum.
How convenient.
The web industry's anniversary gala.
Wow, that's so convenient.
James, if web is a target, we can't sit on this.
I need to issue an alert.
Don't.
He'll only slip away again.
I need time Be quick about it.
I've updated your watch tracker.
See if you can't get a closer fix on the signal like Wow
Boy, I thought my apartment is literally right next to this
guy's gala
Yeah What a coincidence
This reveal better be worth the trouble from what I hear you
won't be disappointed good timing I need to try recharge my
phone rather a lot of security for an office party isn't
there so this is strictly an invitation only event I know
yeah I was totally invited well then the gala is down the
hall enjoy yeah in the main hall directly behind me now who
has my invitation Ouch.
Take it easy.
Hey, hey, why did you err?
Goink.
Beg your pardon?
Yes, ma'am.
Yes, sir.
Much appreciated.
Just have your invitation ready for my colleague at the
entrance.
Is there somewhere I can leave my jacket for the night?
Click room to the left of the entrance.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
You'll find the champagne inside too.
And join the cabin to remind me.
Let's see.
I got recharged everything.
Oh, my dear.
Don't be such a grunt.
Is that a good look for you?
Oh.
the guy here too and yet grab his tablet
credit where credit is due that's also yeah they did not
hear the fucking 80 gun shots earlier that's true must have
been the wind maybe it was fate he died when he died if he
hadn't I wonder if the company would have been able to
weather the storm in the noughties I doubt it would be here
if Nicholas wasn't at the helm.
I don't even wonder what it'd be like.
Here's my past.
Make it till you make it.
Go in with confidence.
Oh.
Wait, this is...
Wait, I know this song.
Bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
This is a classic.
Bum.
Get you something, sir.
Shaking mustard.
Champagne.
Perhaps something a little stronger.
I'm looking for my friend.
Tall, blonde.
Say the line, bond.
Would he be the one who gave you that makeover?
Oh, oh, there he is.
Something like that.
Oh my god.
Nine out of ten.
He didn't say the line.
He literally, the bartender literally said it up for him.
I suppose.
He said it up perfectly.
He said it.
I can't believe it.
Wait, there's the queen.
Oh, she got knighted by the queen.
Oh, my God.
Queen Elizabeth is canon.
Well, I mean, yeah, she was since the Olympics, but still.
She's canon in the reboot.
For those who didn't know, she's canon in the James Bond
universe because she, like, she joined the Olympics, the
queen and Daniel Craig, like.
Did a little skit.
Just a good guess.
Yeah.
Just part of the change bond universe.
Alright.
Well he went that way.
So.
That's where he went.
People say Webb's planning some big tech demonstration
tonight.
Oh.
I hear half the cabinet's here.
David.
There are free drinks.
I'm surprised the entire cabinet isn't here.
It went this way, I'm pretty sure.
What's that over there?
I can play the radio.
That's pretty weird.
What was your purpose here?
Poster for an upcoming solo concert, world-renowned
Czechoslovakian, self-jealous.
I need a key card, but who has it?
Excuse me there, sir.
Who has the key card?
Are you a security guard?
No.
I can't get past these guys.
Okay, find the assassin.
He went that way.
I literally saw him go that way.
There's no denying that the impact is already profound.
Just look at the business sectors like healthcare, customer
service, and the automobile industry.
And let's not forget what it's done for medical research.
Zach.
Whether we like it or not, AI is here to stay.
I don't trust any of the story about, let alone some
algorithm.
I fear our eventual over-reliance on it will result in the
end of blue and white color jobs.
Oh, it's the AI debate.
The man is an idealist and has somehow become a
self-appointed.
Oh, he's over there.
He's a utopian obsessed with the idea of removing human
error through machines.
He's one of those guys.
If he overheard you saying that, you may well find yourself
struck off the famed web there's card list boo-hoo i've got
more important things to worry about hey what's that what is
that
you get out of here just waiting for the private tour to
start yeah get out of here i don't have time for this
another time then i want to see what this is a media kit
wait there's nothing here What was the point of being here?
What the fuck?
Nothing even relevant back here.
You guys don't even have anything important for me.
A robot's not gonna fix my toilet.
Not yet.
Technically, if you think about it, it's like...
Oh, what's it called?
It's like... It's basically the Japanese toilets though
technically oh
it's this way
oh he's in the bathroom search the area oh yes he's in here
tell
me you caught him no it looks like CCTV did if I access the
camera feed can you locate him you'd have to patch me
directly into cctv network terminal go to the security room
it's first floor east wing staff office yeah got it let's
get a spot up close for the big speech pardon me so we can
use it for the warm glow of oh oh it's the performance she's
singing yay free concert
I won't be surprised to take it to this like cost my yearly
paycheck.
Government work does not pay as well as you think it does.
Unless you take bribes.
Mom.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I don't know.
I'll figure out how to grab the staff card.
I don't recognize him.
Do you?
I've never seen him before.
One of the tech interns, maybe.
Looks you enough.
I don't have a staff card.
Who has the key card?
Uh...
Where is he?
None of these have cards.
Okay, let's see.
I could do...
Resistant.
Oh, they don't get affected.
Oh, I can't use drop this.
Loki would never accept bribe.
See the super chat, Tom.
Thank you, thank you.
That's a lie.
You know I would.
Everyone has a price.
Not even going to pretend.
He's a right pain in the ass.
need to stop covering for him no he's my mate but he's
really testing me right now okay there's a guard that's
always late let me make it love okay speak to the security
guard this one staff only Stephen bright security detail are
we down a man I asked for every available body tonight to
ensure the safety of the foreign secretary and his guests I
know I know I should be at the entrance, but I'm covering
for a no-show.
You could always call one of the lads from the day shift
back in to help you out.
There's a security roster behind the counter in the cafe.
There should be contact details for everyone on it.
You know, I should hope so.
All right.
I'm going to go back to the cafe.
Staff wrote it to learn the guard's name.
All right, cafe is over there.
I was there for a little bit.
What is...
is it password think I shall think sorted I can't remember
the login details in the drawer oh thanks all right tablet
credentials see yeah so that's what it's that guess I'll
check yep yes you will what's that
I don't know what was that move whatever shift one Mike
Harry Robert there we go guess he didn't see me it must
stand very still the other bartender did not see me I didn't
forget I told you about this last week all sorted mate my
boss invited me when he invited me Harry Sykes is here head
to your post and I'll take over I need a word with our
friend about the importance of timekeeping.
Must have been the wind.
Maybe you'll finally get through that thick skull of his.
What?
What was that?
Here's to you, Harry.
Yeah, what was that?
I mean, it's fine.
Oh, not fine.
We'll make him sick just for fun.
He's going to have him.
You know what?
Just ruin his day a little bit.
Let's see.
It's a security room.
But I want to open that door.
Oh, this has to be the security room.
Oh,
that could have been my...
That's what the other way was for!
Okay.
Alright.
And there's the other way right here.
Oh!
There's several... I like that.
There's like lots of replayability.
It's like basically not every playthrough is the same.
So you can do, like, there's different strategies on how to
break in.
It's different ways to play the game.
Security should be on the other side of this room.
Can I kill them?
Do I contain them?
Or...
I wonder if I can kill them.
There's a lot of them.
So I'm, like, wondering.
If he gets closer and it shows up, oh, I can.
Oh, yeah, it should be that one.
Where are you going?
Yeah.
Museum education.
Received complaints from guests that chivalry was dead.
Taking a look to see how we can turn the excitement levels
up here.
I can't say I blame them.
Good shout.
It's that easy.
I'll do that.
that real quick all right guess i'll just casually walk up
to the next area now not bad james not bad at all just that
easy very unfortunate that guy got blinded and also started
throwing up wonder who could have done it security is over
there You got lucky, you got chosen.
Now I have a better angle.
That better vantage point for the concert.
I don't know.
She looked at me, guys.
Oh my gosh, she loves me.
Did you guys see that?
Our eyes locked.
She was singing that song to me.
sir this area is off limits mi6 we have a potential security
threat i need access to the cctv feed and i need it now
right sure you are listen son my name is simon and simon
says go back to the gala have yourself a glass of bubbles
and try not to worry that pretty little head of yours we've
got everything under control here tonight you need to listen
to me feet or head first You choose.
Do I not have, like, a little, like, FBI?
Oh, I guess because MI6 is, like, more secretive.
Can I just open it?
CCTV room is through here.
I guess I can.
He's like, you're not allowed in here.
I'm like, what if I just say?
What if I just go in there?
sigh wonder what got me that bad
bingo I guess I should have done that first
hmm excuse me right you lost take it easy I'm not looking
for a fight I didn't hear that i said i wasn't looking for a
fight and i was right i was not that's crazy i could just
walk right in
yeah thank god there was a lot of cubbies big night like
this you think you'd be down there in the middle of order
shaking everyone's hands and cutting deals with half a
downing street i'll be in the office if anyone's looking for
the key card for the cctv room just have them all right god
we'll do okay he has the key card oh is that no no is that
who would that be
yeah everybody's on their phones that's good
oh my god how the do i do this i don't have enough
stuff oh that's close need to see your ID really you saw it
last time you came by two guards two keys thank you director
Hamilton what's that yes it was nobody okay I'm just gonna
you saw it last time you came by grab this I think we've
established that I work here sir you've got some sort of
problem knock it off mike next time you'll what ask me for
my id damn huh
what excuse me yeah you in the right right there just
bluffing just bluffing all right guys it's time take it easy
i don't want any trouble don't tempt me all right guys it's
time I guess, I guess we're containing.
I guess, I guess it's containing time.
I just wanted the bluff.
Why won't you let me?
Oh, God.
No!
I wanted to contain them all.
Okay, he wouldn't let me bluff.
I accidentally got too aggressive.
Good bond was contained.
Alright, don't worry, don't worry.
Take two.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, do I not?
That fucking sucks.
Okay, it's alright.
Everybody put their phones away.
entrance as much as he loves the spotlight and you look a
little out of place anything i can do i don't want any
trouble do you think they saw me oh shit
it's all right i'm containing the situation
throw it situation shall be contained oh shit oh my god wait
i want to go too somebody corner hit we need my way Okay,
this is bad.
This is...
Okay, all right, all right.
If they gave me a gun, this would be a different story.
If they gave me a situation...
All right, continue to round three.
All right, this time.
He is strong.
He is fucking strong.
I can't bluff my way out.
No sign of Sir Nicholas yet.
Big night like this you think you'd be down there in the
middle of order shaking everyone's hands and cutting deals
with half a down industry Like this I'm fucking walking this
way If anyone's looking for the key card for the CCTV room
just have them radio and come find me.
All right gov we'll do Okay Only I can contain him
He's resist oh he's resistant Now I knew
Fucking course he's resistance.
Let's see now.
He doesn't know.
He's resistant to containers.
Oh shit, wait, that's a lot of bot people.
Wait a minute.
he's out cold what could have done that sweep the area now
understood okay well the other way right
closer looks good closer very closer what damn thing focus
stop Oh god I got I can take it's contained now there you go
it's not everything is okay everything bingo there we go see
See guys, nothing to worry about.
Moving on.
Now I got the room.
Okay, on the upper floor.
I gotta make sure I get there.
There is the upper floor.
Oh?
If he was from MI6 told us.
If he was from MI6, I'm from the North Pole.
If something goes down here tonight, Where the fuck?
How do I get up top?
Is it there?
How do I even get up there?
Or is the second floor?
guys where the fuck's the second floor quite a party tech
army and government so Nicholas has the meeting out the palm
of his arm okay the foreign secretary I guess over there a
bit overkill on the manpower don't you think but they really
need this many boots on the ground for a gala I have a bad
question if you were in would you put your life or the life
of all those billionaires and politicians down there and the
ends of a bunch of flat-footed renter cops well where will
he go bye is this store unlocked okay thank God all right
okay that door was unlocked that's good what hello you
looking for someone
Oh, shit, wrong one!
It's a...
Yeah, we're contained.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
Copy the container.
Oh, well, then.
Looks like another situation has been contained.
All right.
Good job, well done.
No, he tripped and fell.
Yeah, did you not see him?
He's so clumsy.
What a clumsy man.
That has been connected to the- You can open, close it
remotely.
All right.
I can just do that.
I recharge this.
All right.
What should I...
What am I not supposed to do down here?
He's such a clumsy man.
Can't believe he just tripped and fell like that.
There's the room.
How do I get in there?
Oh, there it is.
Ah.
Nobody's here.
Wild.
I'm at the terminal.
Nobody's at the big CCTV room to surveillance, this
high-ticket area.
Really nobody is here.
In a gala filled with very important rich people.
Nobody is here.
All right.
But yet so many people are out there.
I don't have the password.
People are lazy.
They probably put it on a post-it note.
Have a look around.
All right, sit tight.
They have to watch this office room.
Yeah, I believe nobody is here.
Oh, yeah.
And then the thing is right here.
Oh, no password here.
Oh, not really.
What's the...
Webgala?
Our starting measures will increase.
Security measures will increase on the night.
Do you think so?
If you...
security guys this is increased security so your staff
on-site access checks and tighter controls around certain
areas of building please ensure that you have your ID on you
at all times and adhere to instructions from our own secure
security personnel as well as webs do not hesitate to reach
out to someone you spot anything unusual during the event
these measures are put in place to ensure everything runs
safely and smoothly many things any luck I've got Hold on.
Yeah, what is normal security?
Harry, HR warning.
This is a form of writing your repeated lightness.
You have been reminded on numerous occasions around the
importance of arriving on time at the H2 has continued.
As a member of the security team, your role is essential to
the smooth running and safety of the works and arts museum.
Your constant tardiness places undue stain and stress on the
rest of the team.
From here on in, you're expected to reward for it for daily
duty on time, but not here.
honeymoon bitch Trey booked us into a gorgeous five-star
hotel in central London we almost caught it quits after that
horrible gas explosion at our digs in Slovakia last week but
now I'm glad we did it kisses I dare say Trey has his hands
full alright it's Harry's fault he was just late that's true
fucking Harry not what I'm looking for that's literal papers
have finished due to a security checklist and empty cups of
tea and coffee serious caffeine dependency is trying and
failing to stay on top of too many things at once is in the
mug employee of the year people really should be more
careful about it what did i tell you put it on the mug he
wrote the security on employee of the irony the fucking
irony about that the password is on employee of the year mug
all right crazy that there's no one here at the like it's
such a high profile event logging in now there i'm in okay
pulling the footage here's your man so much for two birds
one stone you have a location basement archives not the
worst place to lay low or plan an ambush not tonight I'm
headed then now.
How do I get out of here?
Reach the basement, I guess, here.
What?
Where's the door?
Okay, I have to go through the front door.
Alright.
Oh, nobody's gonna turn around?
I mean, alright.
No one's alright.
The best security has to offer.
You'd be surprised where I would find credentials.
Bottom of mug is at least creative.
Thank you for the super chat, El.
Thank you.
Is someone there?
No.
Can't see.
My eyes.
No.
I went the wrong way.
Who's there?
Yes, we'll never know.
Boop.
Just a wind.
I guess we'll never know.
I mean, the dog matter.
So you don't...
I mean, he was, like, in that area.
Peak security, by the way.
Or a tech company, too.
Tech company security.
right there.
Oh, playing this game reminded me of that video of this guy,
um, letting his girlfriend, who doesn't play video games,
like, who's a normie, play, I don't know if you guys saw
that video, play Cyberpunk, and she was complaining about
how, like, a lot of games are not new friendly, because
she's like, what the fuck is a hub?
I don't know what a hub is.
How do I know which is stamina?
I don't know which bar is the stamina bar.
Like, I thought stamina bar was blue.
Are you talking, telling me that's, is this the green bar?
What's the red bar?
she was so lost she was like what the fuck is a HUD someone
explained to me what a hub is like she didn't even
understand that like red bar was health blue bar was magic
sorry Baz I don't think she should understand this game if
she tried to play it yeah my girlfriend yeah it was
basically was like oh i let my girlfriend i uh uh i try to
get my girlfriend to play cyberpunk
all right if only it was this easy all the time if only
well this all looks rather ominous
oh allowed to have a gun
looks like a trap do you think this twin knows how to shoot
maybe they thought maybe one twin is a good shot and the
other one is like just there and they got confused they're
like they gave the wrong twin the gun
one's the melee twin the other's a the other's the shooter
twin One's running melee build, the other one's range.
Come on, think, James.
It has to be something I can use.
Oh.
Nice.
If I need more...
Do you notice me?
No, you don't.
Where am I?
It must be something I can use here.
Oh, where am I?
Oh.
I'm the Rosie.
Ash is.
Ash is the y'all.
Okay.
I really need them to go this way.
Just go the other way.
Okay.
so I can activate this.
There we go.
That's gonna activate, though.
Yeah.
He knows.
Where could I be?
Okay.
Oh, he's stuck.
Okay, that's good for me, actually.
Must be something I can use to get to him.
Okay.
Where's the next?
Okay, this one.
Alright, we'll use this.
It could be the same twin.
He has the melee build.
What?
Oh.
Where am I?
Come on, think, James.
Think.
It has to be something I can use.
Where could I have gone?
It's a little ring around the rosy.
Huh?
Must be something I can use here.
You think he knows?
Okay, I have an idea.
I think I know.
There we go.
Something I can use to get to it.
Right here.
Not again.
There we go!
Yeah!
You beat it!
You fucking beat it!
You're getting rage baited so high.
I'm fucking right.
Oh shit, that's gonna land on him, isn't it?
Oh, nope, he's still okay.
Rage paid successful.
Oh, shit.
That was from Monroe.
Oh, damn.
Awaiting authorization from Webb.
Understood.
Newer.
web operative fucking it's fucking new it
they're there it's terrible murder money penny it's web the
murtos are working for nicholas bloody web he's behind
everything james so obvious i know what i heard i need to
get a hold of greenway he's next already tried he's off the
grid james he's off the grid We need to inform em no time.
I'm going after him.
Make him call off the attack.
Are you out of your mind?
Nicholas Webb is one of the most powerful men in Britain.
What if em's evil?
That's why he has she has lying.
Can you trace the second attack team?
It does look like it's transmitting a geolocation signal to
a device inside the building.
There has to be web.
He commands the assassins.
Tell me you can hack it.
From a bathroom stool at the night errant.
Not a chance.
evil they're all evil except for me you just get close to
web and I handle the rest I only need a few minutes to
update the software yeah where I just fucking break the door
I don't find web I'm supposed to fucking get out of here
where Where the fuck is the key card?
Okay.
Maybe they're all corrupt.
What?
Oh, the one time I can't just smash the fucking door.
I can't.
Where the fuck is the key card?
All I have are batteries.
Oh, there it is.
There's the fucking key card.
God damn it.
Need to confront Webb.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, apparently that glass is smashed, but I can't smash my
own glass.
Alright, here I go.
This mission is long.
Guess that's the only way I could go.
Hey.
The door was jammed.
Yeah, just yeah, just inspecting the doors guys Yeah, I'm
such a good spy.
I don't never know
Hey Where are you web?
Oh, oh my bond girl What she doing here in time?
Yeah, must say you look astonishing for your age agent Roth
hardly a day over 50.
What do you expect an apology?
How about an explanation?
Later.
Just play along.
Damien.
What?
I'm not interrupting anything.
You're not.
Damien, meet Mr. Beach.
Was it?
Mr. Beach.
James Bond.
James Beach?
Well.
Lately.
Headhunting.
Oh dear.
I do hope you're not plotting on stealing Isola here.
I took such trouble in hiring her.
She really is.
Rather brilliant.
quite the catch I'm not making any promises hmm what do you
know I'm out excuse me gentlemen I'd be careful with this
one James dare I say out of your life what if she feels bad
about me no no yeah she likes a bad boy yeah well Well, uh,
welcome all.
Tonight, we celebrate the history of web industries.
But merely looking back would be complacent.
Personally, I prefer to look ahead.
For more than a century.
Oh my God, it's the Boston robot.
It's safe for the future.
It's done.
I've updated your watch.
The hack starts automatically when you're within three feet
of the target.
On it.
And yet I want us to aim higher.
I believe technology has the power to elevate.
Watch it.
Oh, I got drugged.
Oh, no, I got drugged.
He's drugged me.
Oh, my God.
dynamics.
They're going to learn Kung Fu.
I got drugged by my bond girl.
I think I'm on...
I think I'm on base one, guys.
Guys, guys.
I think I'm on the first base, guys.
I'm on first base now, if she dragged me.
Base one.
whip once you lose it
oh wait she also got drunk wasted no time no she wasted mine
wait is that her son how did you allow her to get this close
is it nicholas's son what is he doing here you know i handle
mi6 they were onto us and i didn't think that we had time
for your back channeling that is precisely the problem you
don't think careful Huh?
Careful, old man.
I knew it.
He's a son.
Oh, what the fuck?
Damien, you sick fuck?
Yes.
There's no time.
There's no time to backpedal and roll in.
I have a full strike team on Greenway.
He is as good as dead.
Now.
Damn.
Clean up your mess.
Ooh, I thought.
The billionaires.
son is a psychopath tell us all this time it needn't have
come to this and i'm truly sorry now it's only cold-blooded
murder don't beat yourself up about it
i'm still gonna try and hack his phone apparently
you okay there you okay there sport very well
well it's they're both evil it's like the family business
the evil business oh is this the homo erotic wild torture
part never accept a drink from a stranger
i guess they didn't teach you that in that little spy school
of yours
It's Casino Royale.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I'm still hacking, though.
No, with your remarks.
Not even the old.
You're never going to get away with this.
Wow, you really are quite disappointing.
That's why you hit like a girl.
You hit like a girl.
Whoa!
Oh!
oh shit i can't i shouldn't provoke him anymore
anything else you'd like to get off your chest i'm curious
what did 009 have yeah he must have posed quite a threat yes
well you've you've seen the t-shirt every crisis is an
opportunity have you told Nico about his brother's untimely
end I do hope he doesn't shoot the messenger just be
grateful that I don't have his patience or his anatomical
know-how oh shit okay guys I don't think I could take
another punch guys I don't might have blown too close to the
Sun we're about done here then my champagne's getting flat
how did you know 009 was in Slovakia and I left do you have
a mole at MI6 you're good I tell you I really would but then
well then I'd have to kill you hmm I'm gonna do that anyway
would you look at the time Joe no I was so close no I
couldn't how I was gonna die I was literally gonna die if I
take another hit guys like
I was gonna fucking die I
Oh, I gotta edge it.
Alright, I guess I got beat up again.
I'm really bad at yapping, apparently.
This is going to be the end of a very short career.
Never accept a drink from a stranger.
I guess they didn't teach you that in that little spy school
of yours.
oh my god please i have to pass this i cannot get i cannot
stand for his monologue again
what no witchy remark not even the old you're never gonna
get away with this wow you really are quite disappointing
tell me something do you always bring sedatives to a party i
should count myself lucky i didn't wake up in your hotel
room Hmm.
All right.
I wasn't kidding.
You really are spectacularly annoying.
Did I stall here or did I provoke him again?
What if I...
Okay.
I provoke him again.
Anything else you'd like to get off your chest?
Have you told Nico about his brother's untimely end?
I do hope he doesn't shoot the messenger.
I just...
What's too late, guys?
I don't have his patience or his...
anatomical know-how oh shit I have to stall here I have to
stall here I'm one hit I'm one punch away from a from a
concussion guys James are we just about done here because my
champagne is getting flat MI6 has the place surrounded
they've heard every word you said have they now you're just
stalling are you You, uh, are you waiting for your mentor to
save you?
Because, believe me, I could take another.
He has his own problems.
I could tank this.
I have to ask.
Do you often let your father scold you like a petulant
child?
I could tough this out.
Don't worry.
Just so, you know, just one or two brain cells ain't too
bad, guys.
Ain't too bad.
Just like two to three brain cells, you know?
I can tank it.
It's a little brain damage.
A little bit of a rest or R&R wouldn't fix.
Okay.
That was invigorating.
I can still...
I can still eat and drink.
Make them disappear.
Huh?
Did they not realize one one chair was missing.
Oh, shit.
I think you threw a straw for a couple of days.
Well, let's find out.
Yeah, they just forgot about it.
We'll have company soon.
I don't suppose you have an exit strategy.
Well, this wasn't exactly a planned visit.
I really planned to get the shit beat out of me.
Quick, check the others.
Check the door three months that's how long i spent
infiltrating web industries and you managed to waste it in
all of 30 seconds it's a gift also locked to be expected no
way out didn't pick you for a quitter so what do i call you
i bet easel isn't your real name either please it's not like
yours is james bond of course not window it is then what are
you doing oh waiting for you james all right
locked eyes don't get used to it is she gonna help me no
time someone's coming she's not i fucking knew it that bitch
yeah off of it management just issued a code wipe back at
the perch all hands on deck and all that data wipe because
of one guy a data wipe awfully quiet isn't it what are you
trying to hide is it worse vince no you two just about done
in there oh they're done all right nope let me just close
the door
james what happened i got it wrong it isn't so nicholas
controlling the kill team it's as I barely escaped.
Tell me your plan worked.
I'm processing.
Piggy backing the signal tracing their coordinates.
Look, we find the kill team.
We find Greenway.
Where are you now?
I'm just happily swarmed by trigger happy mercenaries.
I need a way out of the museum.
Already on it.
Oh, nice.
Wait, not nice.
I don't have a gun.
Whoever this guy is, he doesn't deserve you.
Oh, let's bring your gun to work day.
How did that...
Okay, you gotta aim it.
Okay.
Alright, this is bad.
I don't have a gun.
Alright, let's find the first guy with a gun and then...
And then we can start talking.
Alright.
Alright, get over here.
Give me your gun.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
Now they have a license to kill.
It's over.
Come on.
Where's the better position?
There we go.
More of the other guns.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to find the other guns.
Okay.
There's no way there was only...
Only one gun!
Get me out of here.
Where's your head?
There we go.
That's better.
You're the last one.
There we go.
Oh.
Or could it be you?
There we go.
Situation contained.
Shouldn't have given me that license.
Frame one shot.
That's their first mistake.
Alright, nice.
How do I get out of here?
It's over here.
Make a little oopsie there.
One shot, one kill.
I assume I thought, yeah.
Yeah, I have to go to the other side.
Parkour!
Just a little performance at the gala.
Just a little show, a little parkour show.
He said contain.
He said thing.
What's this?
The eight of roses.
Not to alarm you, but an armed unit's just derive from web
industries hq i must have made an impression any advice send
them in nice
always good send them all in i'm ready for you more target
practice for me where am i supposed to go
secure.
Watch your backs.
Keep your eye out for anyone suspicious.
FYI, Saunders and White have Northexit keycards.
If anyone's looking... I'll be needing that keycard.
Hello?
Get in there.
That's my way out.
Contained.
They'll be fine.
He's so healthy.
Alright.
Now I gotta figure out where to go.
It's all the way across from me.
So...
Let's see...
Or I could just shoot all of them.
Never cared much for one.
No?
Oh, yeah.
I just want to shoot them.
Hmm.
Nothing noteworthy.
Take it easy.
I'm not looking for a fight.
Keep your hands.
But I am.
I'm looking for a fight!
That's right.
Huh!
Get out of here!
Nice.
It's got to worry about me.
There we go.
Okay, we gotta figure out where the other key card is.
Uh, stop.
Then recharge.
Just didn't know.
They're stupid.
Ah.
Hey.
Come out if anyone's there.
Take it easy.
I don't want any trouble.
Oh, shit.
That's looking right.
Tell your wife!
I can't wait to see her tonight!
That's right.
There you go.
Alright.
Alright, the others.
Not yet.
Don't have a name or a description yet.
Which I know doesn't do as much good right now, but just
keep your eyes peeled.
Stay alert.
Let's see.
I don't even know who it is you're supposed to be looking
for.
Just look.
I don't want...
I mean, they can't see shit.
Because they're blinded.
Get it?
He's like, what happened to him?
Oh, yeah?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Five dodged it.
Oh, fuck.
Holy shit.
containing me oh my god oh my god he's containing me right
now what do i do oh my god i'm trying to get away from him
i'm trying to dodge i swear to god
whoa no whoa
Okay, just keep containing him.
Oh, my God.
Bro,
this man's a fucking fighter.
Bro, God, join the MMA.
He's a joint.
That's a great...
Got you now, bitch.
This is the best W.
WWE game ever made episode.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got signed that man up That guy's an MMA fighter right
there.
Someone signed him up Do you see me
Closer Hey, you got close Am I there yet?
Oh shit, that's a lot of people.
I hear something, not far away.
No, you know it.
Not important.
Let it wait.
Does it know?
Oh shit!
No!
It's alright!
It's fine!
I got experience for that MMA fighter.
There you go.
Lonnie, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Next wrestlers here are going to be multiplayer mod for this
game.
Jordan, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
How terrified to know that the spy is psychophobic because
he starts doing jokes while beating your ass.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Am I there yet?
I lost track of the objective.
Oh my god, it's all the way down there
God, just Fuck it Alright guys I'm done I'm done playing
this Melee game Alright everybody I'm done I'm done playing
this Melee game Bring out your guns now, I'm ready Identify
your, stop right now Take it easy Oh Saunders I just got
word the suspect was spotted on the rooftop gotten past you
already slippery bastard yeah he's about white too best find
him then all right that's how you do it i mean i guess that
works
well is
he breathing i'm gonna move on moving to the next location
you think he knows Oh There you go There you go situation
contained again All right, that's it.
I'm ready.
Give me the guns.
Give me the guns Oh my god shoot the kill shoot the kill
license the kill
That's right.
That's fucking right.
It's time.
I don't need a shot.
Where are you?
All right, where are you?
Just to be a little fancy.
Hey, open up.
There we go.
There you go.
Finally, I got permission.
Where's the rest of you?
I've had enough.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, more like just me.
All right, we contained the situation.
We got the key card, guys.
We did it.
I would have gone to waste anyway.
What I expected British spy drama.
What I got, Donnie in martial arts movie.
And a splash of apex.
Ravs, absolutely.
He was super chat thinking, thank you.
Oh, he did it, guys.
James Bun.
Situation contained.
As always.
What the fuck?
Is he 3D printing?
Oh my god, it is.
What can I do?
Oh, low vision.
Screen.
Oh, that's freaky.
I like it.
is at the historical target period the ai constructs
a reptile male mid-20s dark hair medium build orders are to
shoot on site they means dogs i presume hey
oh my god okay i did not realize their guns are stronger
that might have been a oopsie
might have been a little bit of an oopsie that's fine I
reload get
rid of his helmet okay there we go nice all right let me
take that battery real quick oh my Oh, there he is.
Oh, nice.
Made him feel a little shit before he dies.
Oh, shit.
I saw my pistols, though.
Don't worry.
I'll get rid of his helmet, I think.
Oh, shit.
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
He's not wearing a helmet.
It's fine.
Alright.
Wait, there's still one more?
Oh, there is more than just one more.
Okay, that's good.
This gun is stronger.
Alright, nice.
Really?
Where could I be?
That was the helmet.
There we go.
Oh, it is?
Wait, give me a sec.
Is it really down to you?
Oh, there you are.
Let me play around with you a little bit.
Oh, we're...
It's down to you.
Just passing through.
All your friends are dead.
Looks like you was the last one.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I thought I could pick that up.
all right look they were the bad guys i have i have
diplomatic immunity for all kills because i was licensed
thank you for your visit i got my license somehow i doubt
that james i have the coordinates transmitting now money
penny you're a lifesaver where's your date anywhere but here
his words his loss i've got the address you'll need a ride
hold on almost out all right
let's see a little maze here
knock knock hello oh shit james james what's happening
where's my gun See, if I killed him, I wouldn't have to run
for cover.
Let me add him.
Oh, my God.
Where could James Bond be?
Where could we be?
What should we do?
Why don't you run me?
They're like...
Not quite.
Keys, where are they?
He's just like, how are we going to get him?
He's behind a box.
A moving box!
BAM!
Oh my god, it's the side!
It's okay, these were the bad guys it's time to take out the
trash another bomb unfortunately i have to drive this myself
was that coca-cola holy that's
right get out of here this is my road
that is some strong-ass british garbage trucks christ half
of kensington would have heard that Holy shit.
And then some.
And what are you talking to me for?
Get a move on.
What was my truck made of?
Grabs, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I told you to go home.
Imagine the game had a river scene just like Metal Gear.
Clearly.
Yeah, but James Bond is about shooting.
Who's been trying to kill us?
Webb.
This is too suspicious.
Of course, Greenway survives, you know?
Final report.
It's so suspicious.
Of course, he survives.
To make the first move.
Why the stash you got here, Greenway?
Oh.
I asked you to make a dead drop earlier.
Old dog, old trick.
Now, Tula, I reckon the laser would prove useful in this
type of situation.
A laser is useful.
Let's grab the...
I want to grab the flash mine.
Oh, recommended?
Oh, is the Dartphone recommended as well?
Yeah, it is.
Oh, but a flash...
Oh, yeah, I'll just use the recommended.
Off we go.
Gentlemen, I've breached the web industry's database, and as
of this moment, you're both upper-middle management.
I'm sure you'll blend right in.
Your IDs will only take you as far as the executive floors.
that's where the real challenge begins oh your final
destination is an impregnable self-contained structure atop
the main building known as the perch none of that stays like
that code white web's deleting all the evidence what can you
tell us about the perch that's just it the place is an
information black hole no blueprints no infrastructure
nothing have I mentioned that This is a terrible idea.
I need to notify M.
M is need to know only.
Her protection, not ours.
Shit up, Moneypenny.
We're not leaving without answers.
Play it cool.
Always.
Evening.
Perch bound, I assume.
Burning the midnight oil.
You work at the Perch?
I work with all departments.
Roger Finch, Chief Legal Officer.
And you are...
Security.
Security officers.
We've been called in to help out with...
Yeah, in case he quizzes me, it'll be fucked.
Well, my department works closely with the CSO's office, and
I don't recall seeing you before.
That's bad.
I got rid of mine.
I see.
You must work closely with McKenzie.
How's he doing?
I haven't seen him all week.
Um...
Really?
I think he was over the moon.
He'd be married and all.
I won't last.
Call me a cynic.
Will you deal with this, Claude, or should I?
I'm so good at this.
Say, I... I didn't catch your name.
It's Jones.
Right.
And you'll come... Oh!
That's awkward.
You fast?
If indeed you are who you say you are.
Oh, now look here.
I think I did pretty well, Greenway.
Something you ate.
Greenway, I think I passed.
Oh, dear God.
Excuse me.
Nailed it, guys.
Alright.
Oh my God, he actually got closer.
You already ate!
What?
No.
Okay, we're going to call it here because I don't know how
long this mission is.
Oh my god.
We're going to call it here.
Like I said, we have such a long... We had two more days of
streams.
And tomorrow I have to be up early too.
So I'm going to call it here, guys.
That has been a really... Oh, I wish I could play.
next week.
I wasn't going on a business trip next week.
Ah, I would have loved to play more.
I really want to play more, but I have to get up early
tomorrow for the Apex tournament, and also I want to make
sure I don't fuck up my voice for next week.
Anyway, guys, it's been really fun.
I've been really enjoying James Bond.
I'm so sad that next week I won't be playing the game next
week.
I just want to see it to the end.
I'm really addicted to this game.
I really enjoy the story.
I really enjoy the gameplay so far but sadly sadly i have to
stop it here got to restrain myself all right guys thank y
'all for watching as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you sit up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye